That is some mind ninja right there. Okay, I'm pregnant and I
don't know what to do. Oh, do you like need money? Can I take
care of the kid? Even though we're broken up, I actually aborted
it. >> Honestly, that's a good friend to you, dude, because
you obviously didn't want a fiance because she's not 13 years
old. >> I suggest finding a reason to live that's not spite.
Okay, there's no chance that he followed up with, "I'm also pro
ICE and I think illegal immigrants should not be in my country.
Okay. [music] All right. All right.
Let's see. What do I have for Chibi Review stuff? [music] I've
got the Techone video. Okay. Reviews says one of the few people
supporting him is Techone. Okay. Reone
is one of his few support systems. Not good, man. So what you'll
get from this guy is he is sort of like the prototypical LCA
who engages with his haters a lot and provokes them a lot and
then deals with the consequences of continue to like cycle through
this a lot. He deals with these consequences a lot. Okay.
I think I think starting with the techone video may be appropriate
here. I think we could actually just start with the techone video
because the tech video will give you all of the context that
you need. He's got to go through the honest. The title of this
video is going to look pretty serious. And trigger warning, uh,
thoughts, cheating, probably worse things than that are going
to be talked about here. I think that we're going to talk about
this because this can be kind of a learn from others mistakes
type of video, as well as why you should push through the pain
in your life. >> Um, now obviously this is a video about
Chibi Reviews. We don't know Chibi. Controversy follows this
guy like the plague. Some would consider it unjustified, some
would consider it justified, but I think we're reaching levels
of terminal velocity that people previously thought were unreachable.
Uh I mean these this guy has been a person who's dealt with,
you know, people dig like going to dig up his brother's corpse
from a grave. Uh doxing him.
>> Now, is that one true? They did dox the location of
his brother's grave site, which is pretty [__] up.
>> Okay, it's really up. And why? They leaked actual pictures
of my house and my brother's grave, so I don't feel safe right
now. Your fans and dead brother. Funny. I shouldn't be laughing.
It's actually really up. Okay. It's really It's really Dude,
the Boruto fans uh one
I never with the Boruto community because I guarantee you the
demographics of the Boruto community, okay, are they're the exact
kind of people you don't want to [__] with. That's
all I'll say. Okay. Especially in the United >> have been
my private information has been leaked online. My pictures of
my dead brother's grave and mocking my grave on top of that.
And then on top of all of this continuous amounts of death threats.
This video is being used as a paper trail for I can show to my
lawyer, also the court system, because I am going to be filing
a lawsuit against the individuals that are responsible for doxing
my private information. Now, as you can see on screen, I already
have a few people that, you know, is not necessarily going to
be potentially in this lawsuit, but I do want to showcase the
actions of what I've been going through throughout this entire
ordeal in the last four. Now, this is like this is the exact
Did he say lawsuit? I don't think he intentionally said lawsuit.
[laughter] I don't think he intentionally said it. I also don't
think he ever filed it to be clear. Or at least I've never seen
I've never seen anybody going over in documents from this.
So,
I just think it's so funny that you start with this tweet because
this tweet's just funny and it's like up. It's like supered up
that you would just go and advertise all of the people dunking
on you. This is like particularly bad LCA behavior. You just
po post like tweets of people dunking on you, right? And you
review tweets of people dunking on you, making you look like
a [__] It's stardust tier behavior, okay? Oh my god,
this guy posted a cow in my replies. Pisco, please ban him. That's
it's stardust level behavior, okay? But from somebody with far
less reason to do so. Okay, he's got viewers. He's got subscribers.
Why is he doing it? Nobody could know. Nobody could possibly
guess. >> 48 hours or so, ever since the first episode
of Dawn to Dawn came out, and I uploaded my video on it this
past Wednesday. So, as you can see here, this is one individual
partaking in the mockery of my brother's death. We have an individual
that is hoping that I basically get uh my brain stem stomped
[laughter] in. >> Sorry.
[__] I should laugh. I shouldn't >> My corpse
is spit on. They went on to have a lot of likes. The post is
still up, by the way. >> Dude, by the way, this is not
like him saying he's gonna find the guy. If I ever saw you in
real life, I would stomp the brain stem out your head and spit
on your shaking corpse. Why? Why? These people are crazy, man.
These people are [__] crazy. >> Is spit on.
They would have a lot of likes. The post is still up, by the
way. Not been terminated or violated any Twitter uh rules or
anything like that. We have people making false thumbnail images
of me trying to slander me, saying I made content like this,
and then trying to say, "Yeah, I made a video on this." When
in reality, I did not. Then we have a post like this where someone
put a petition out to stone me to death. Aka, there was thousands
of people that liked this post. This was an early on screenshot.
Sadly, I didn't get a late stage screenshot.
How is this slander when it's the same scene, animators went
hard?
How is this part slander, but then you you said the animators
didn't need to go so hard for this scene and it's your tweet
that's getting quote tweeted? Like how wait, what part of this
is slander? Maybe you didn't make it with this precise thumbnail
or something,
but like it's clearly the same scene with the same implications
and this is your opinion. >> Petition out to stone. >> What
is Boruto? Boruto is the follow-up to Nar with Nar's son. Boruto.
That's about Nar's son. Boruto. I I guess that might also be
him. Maybe they did a time skip as well.
Yeah, it's an anime. Yep. Me to death. Aka, there was thousands
of people that liked this post. This was early on screenshot.
Sadly, I didn't get a latestage screenshot, but the last time
I saw the post is likes before it got removed thanks to violations
of Twitter's terms and service. It had 12,000 likes, aka 12,000
people were wishing for my death. And so, we escalate all this
that's been happening for the last few days to the point to where
my private information has been doxed. And now, the threats or
death threats that I have been receiving are all more real. very
very much real when someone posts pictures of my house and my
brother's grave. FYI, I don't like to talk about this much. I
talked about it briefly
a long time ago because anime snob can't believe I mentioned
that man's name again. He mocked my brother's death as well.
They committed
and obviously I'm assuming this individual is probably from that
rabid group from a long time ago. I could be wrong. We'll find
out when uh
>> keep looking at Chibi and thinking he must be related
to Drew Pavloo. There's a connection there. A spiritual one,
if not a genetic one. There is a connection. Okay. Very very
similar behaviors, similar
like online danger responses. Okay. I'm just going to I'm going
to post every time somebody like totally raped me online in a
row and then I'm going to say that this is this is crazy. Also,
I sus
nothing. Also, I suspect communism is at play. Okay. the lawsuit
gets underway. But the point of the matter is is that um I am
a little bit concerned about my safety because obviously my girlfriend
lives with me. I have two dogs that I love and a cat as well.
Obviously I'm concerned. I mean definitely after having 10 plus
thousand people wishing for my >> Now it's totally reasonable
to be concerned.
I do think that usually the unfortunate thing with a lot of stuff
like doxing is is the more you blow it up, the more you talk
about um like the more you explicitly go and say I was doxed,
the more likely it is for somebody to find and do something with
that information, right? So, so like that's why this is just
a bad tactic probably. And literally, you can go into any of
my recent tweets and look at the quote retweets and seeing people
actively justifying
death threats against me. It's very clear that I do have some
cause for concern. So, thankfully, I live in Tennessee. I don't
live in uh California or anything. I'm able to legally own a
gun. I've owned this for a while. Yeah.
>> Now, anything
very important element here. Okay. He's allowed to own a gun.
>> That's going to be pretty important. Okay.
It's going to be pretty important. Okay. Because
was this was this gun just for show or
it may have may have been just for show. >> I've owned
this for a while and I'm going to tell you right now, if anyone
wants to pull any stupid games, you're going to win stupid prizes.
That's all I'm going to say. What I will say now, going one step
further, I'm going to end this video here for legal reasons as
well. But I am going to be protecting myself. I am definitely
someone that will be watching. And if you know, now I got the
evidence. I got screenshots. Those that you know are involved
in this, you will definitely [laughter] be
>> dude. [laughter]
Okay. All right. He did lose everything,
Okay. Also, I should probably actually go to his primary tweets
and just show these real quick just in case you missed this last
night. Okay, this is two days ago. He tweeted, "I want to die."
Then he followed up with a Twitter post of him in the hospital.
Okay. And then he deleted that one and he says, "Deleted the
post with my hospital armband to clarify. I am fine and was discharged
this morning from the hospital. I had a mental break and I did
almost die last night, but I was saved at the last moment. Honestly,
don't want to elaborate too much further on it if I can help
it."
And then he posts the video. Okay,
so this was two days ago. Oh, he had the mental break and then
yesterday he was released from the hospital and he posted the
video last night.
All right.
Okay. So, without further ado, we might as well continue on with
the Tech video. I just want to go and see the Boruto fandom thing
cuz I think they they might have like looked up they might have
found a picture of his brother's gravestone or something which
is crazy. I don't think they tried to dig his brother up. His
techone just deserted >> that people previously thought
were unreachable. Uh, I mean these this guy >> Why did
he lose everything? His girlfriend broke up with him. Oh, don't
worry, Orange Kush. You're about to find >> Has been a
person who's done all of it. >> You know, people dig like
going to dig up his brother's corpse from a grave. Uh, doxing
him, doxing his family, frequent swatting. Um, and now it's reached
his personal life where he's having issues with his once fiance.
Uh, and this is a story about a man who lost everything. Um,
in case you guys didn't know why I misstreamed the other day,
and I did this out of choice, because I wanted to. I was very
worried about Chibi. Uh, me and Nicholas were talking about trying
to make sure if we could find this guy, make sure he's okay.
We got the police involved. And thankfully, you know, he's still
here today with us, but it was a very scary situation. And I
want to let you guys know right now, never kill yourself. Um,
if you're experiencing
thoughts, please reach out to someone that you trust and talk
to them about it. Uh, your life is worth I didn't I didn't quite
have the strength to go where dead domain went. Okay, there's
a there's a dead domain tweet out there that basically says like
wait techone save this guy. Oh, so just one more reason to hate
this guy. [laughter] I didn't quite have the strength to do that
last night. I'm still on the I'm pretty firmly in the never give
yourself bandwagon. Okay, but they do they do give one pause.
Okay, they these guys they do give one pause. >> Worth
living and the world is better with you in it. I believe as a
man
that we all are going to live painful experiences. We are uh
we're all going to live very painful lives. Uh
are we? I don't think we're all going to live the kind of pain
that Chibi Chippy Reviews has gone through. I don't I don't think
so.
This might be one of those things where
like I get it. Just wait until you hear precisely the circumstances.
If you feel like, yeah, never kill yourself. there. Nothing bad
enough could happen that you want to just wait like listen to
what happened to him. Okay. >> Every man's life is forged
by pain and all great men have lived very painful lives. That's
the truth. Um if you live a soft >> Tell me that again
life. No one. >> Hold on. >> Uh live painful experiences.
>> We are as a man
>> that we all are going to live painful
>> Thank you. We're all going to live very painful lives.
Uh, every man's life is forged by pain and all great men have
lived very painful lives. That's the truth. Um, if you live a
soft, squishy >> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, Marcus.
Thank you. Thank you, Marcus Aurelius.
Thank you. Thank you. >> Life, no one is going to remember
you. So, cherish the fact that you've endured pain because others
get to learn by what you went through. And that and your pain
will give others strength. So, find comfort in it because it's
going to come very fast. If you're doing anything worthwhile,
everything hard in life is
that anything that's worth doing is going to be hard in life.
So, find comfort and struggle and embrace the struggle. Do not
let it consume you. We're going to watch this video. I would
love you guys to send support to Chibi. Um, and let's get into
it. This is going to be a very painful one, guys. Um, but I have
gotten Chiby's
permission to react to this because I think sharing his story
is important because what this guy overcame and endured and what
we'll continue to push through, I believe everybody else can
also push through. But this will be the story of a man who quite
literally,
how does that conversation go?
How does that conversation even go?
Hey, man. I know your life's in tatters. I'm glad that you're
okay and you're not thinking about doing anything drastic anymore.
I have a very important
Can I react to your content stream? >> Has lost nearly
everything,
>> but I'm going to explain to you hopefully after why
there's a certain beauty in that and why what tragedy seems like
in one person's life could end up being the best thing to happen
for him. Let's get into it. >> I'm making this video
as more of a statement to myself.
This video is for me to put all my
my fault. >> By the way, now that I've watched the video
before, what was the statement to himself? Like, I'm I'm the
most rich man on planet Earth. Is that is that the statement
he was making? Cuz I didn't hear him like come up with a plan.
I didn't hear him do anything that sounded positive. He basically
just trauma dumped and peeled out. Okay. There was like almost
nothing there. thoughts together and just
work things out in my own way. Because one of the ways I've always
um gotten through trauma
and hardships in my life, especially in these last years, is
to just focus on work. >> To [sighs] Yep. >> make
videos.
>> Oh, am I over tone? Give me a second.
>> There we go.
That >> I really have. Yep.
>> I've talked a lot to Chibi over the past couple of couple
of days. Um, and I think that him and I have had a very parallel
experience for what he's currently going through. And I I I really
because what I said to him helped him quite a lot. So, if anybody's
ever experienced anything like what you're about to hear, um,
Miz is going to be celebrating this and dunking endlessly on
it, isn't he? Well,
you tell me. Hold
Oh, do I not have a tweet here? God damn it. Hold on. Cuz yeah,
there is there is a tweet. Okay. Oh, wait. It spoils.
>> Yes. Suffice to say, we'll watch the M clip when it
comes up. Okay. >> Amongst the dark, but >> we'll
watch the Miz clip when it comes >> Be willing to fight
in order to get >> Yes, he [clears throat] is celebrating.
>> You all saw the post. You all have seen You've seen
what I've said in the last
24 how many hours? I don't know. This is
I'm just going to give you a full rundown of just everything
that that
>> Maybe I'm oversharing.
This will be used against me to mock me or whatever. >> It
will. Uh it it absolutely will. Um
sharing intimate moments with your chat
>> um is a perfectly, you know, okay thing to do. But anybody
who would
>> Is it though?
Is it though?
I don't know. It's Maybe it's like okay.
Maybe it's hard to judge, but I do think stuff like this
uh it it just creates issues. It really creates issues. There's
I don't know if I could define a precise harm to it, but it does
create like major issues. It gets people way too attached to
you, right? It feeds into like parasociality
and it doesn't get you anything positive. It just creates people
who feel like indebted to you somehow to like make you feel better.
Just farms those people.
It's It's not great, man.
>> Techone does it as a manipulation strategy. Most people
do it as a manipulation strategy to be honest. Um there's just
some times where like that manipulation is required. There are
times where you're really sad probably if you're crying it's
like essentially you asking for help, right?
like you're you're letting your emotions flow out. You might
be able to do it. Like if you're crying somewhere publicly, I
should say like you could go somewhere private.
It's like it is sort of a manipulation. It's just like sometimes
justifiable or
Not like a negative connotation manipulation. It's just you want
a reaction for people. >> Will use your moments of weakness
against you forever because these people are not human. Um they're
lizard people and they're willing to I'm being real. They're
they're trying to get people to kill themselves. They really
are. Um
there will be people that will root for my death. There will
be people that will root for Asthma Gold's death. I mean, you
know, there are people that root for Chiby's death. Um
>> I don't think I I don't root for Asminold's death. I
don't root for Chiby's death. I
keep my thoughts about Teone to myself. >> They are quite
literally trying to get you to keep yourself. I want to remind
you that when Asminold's mom died,
Hassan mocked Asminold for that and said that he caused his own
mother death. Um, his own mother death. Did Did Hassan say Asminold
caused his own mother's death? I'll fix it for him. His own mother
deaths.
His own's mother death. I was laughing right alongside Hassan.
I've heard a lot of people say that. I just I think Hassan usually
tries to rise above that stuff, right? From what I've seen,
I I think. But there's our first Hassan is bad. What What did
that have to do with anything here? What did Hassan have to do
with anything here? I have no
Why did Hassan just get invoked? Why did he just get brought
up? I have no idea. But he did. For some reason, we had a Hassan
is bad moment.
>> And I can't tell you why. I literally I can't explain
why, >> but it just they come out of nowhere for these
people. >> These are demons. These are lizards and human
skin. Uh they are horrific people. And you will notice that they're
all originating from one side. >> Well, like I said, I'm
saying all this.
>> I know the I know the ideology Tech is pretending to
to like avow and explain to people and support far better than
he does. Okay, that's actually insane that he said, "Oh, it's
all lefty people." No, it's not. No, it's not.
I could talk circles around this about any right-wing politics,
okay? It's actually crazy that he tries to invoke politics over
this. >> Just
come on, man. Come on, bro. >> To clear my head. Just >> Cuz
if I say it,
it's it's done. It's It's over. like I'm able to just process
everything at least a little bit better. >> Moss [__]
is the worst. MOSSPIKER IS THE WORST. COMMIES.
COMMIES. >> So on the 11th of February, I discover I discover
my fiance
cheating on me with my best friend of 10 >> There's the
punch line. Okay, there's the there's like the imit immediate
punchline. All right, if you didn't know what happened at Chippy
Reviews,
that's what happened at Chippy Reviews. Okay, but wait, there's
more. We could do the Billy Mays thing, but wait, there's more.
Okay, >> I confronted her about >> I had a conversation
with him about this and I told him exactly what his fiance was
going to do and I hated how I was >> and um she apologized
and I being with her already for multiple years and then finding
out my best friend. So much
>> So much betrayal. Okay, now we can do the miscl >> discover
my fiance.
>> Now we could do the misclick. >> Cheating on me
with my best friend of 10. [laughter] >> Also, if you guys
think I'm a bad person, just wait.
>> All right.
Woo. [screaming]
Good for her. Good for her. Congratulations, lady. Congratulations.
You finally moved on. Get the hell out of there. Good [laughter]
job. Honestly, that's a good friend to you, dude, because you
obviously didn't want a fiance because she's not 13 years old.
So, good for her. Good friend and good fiance. I'm proud of them.
Good job, guys. Good job all around. All good. Good applause.
Good applause. Honestly, this calls for a celebration, chat.
Another [laughter] >> to break out the [__]
>> wine from when I was with my doctor the other night.
And we could celebrate a little bit early. I mean, hey, I'm going
out tonight with some of my friends who are all over the age
of 21, by the way. Actually, they're all like 30 years old. Let's
have some wine Friday,
Just a nice little glass of wine.
>> It's Friday. Let's go. We >> sip on while we listen
to this. >> And then I drove. >> Okay,
we'll pause there. We don't want to We don't want to spoil. We
got to go back to Techone. Okay. >> Losing your best friend
and your wife in the same time is it's awful, man. >> Live
Miz reaction right here. >> People you've done the most
for and they both betray you at the same time. >> Chibi
was hardly an enemy of Miz, was he? Uh, no. No, no, that's not
true. That's not true. Uh when Miz was going after Techone, Chibi
Reviews was one of the guys who was getting in the paint being
like, "You can't trust Misk. He abused Emmy. YOU CAN'T TRUST
MISK. He's lying. He's lying."
And then this happened to him. Okay. Miz already hated Chibi
Reviews because of how Chibi Reviews acted on Twitter when Miz
was talking about the Technone case.
And they're not hardly enemies. They are they're actual enemies.
>> So what I decided to do
is just I grabbed my keys. I went
>> He went driving.
>> I went to the liquor store.
I bought alcohol that was the same
the last alcohol that I drank with my
>> his brother passed away.
It was horrible, man. Jesus. >> And then I drove [sighs]
>> Hold on, hold on. He had a He had a tweet in the previous
thing. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. [laughter]
>> Sorry. Uh, what does this tweet say? Your fans and dead
brother.
>> Let's go. [laughter] Back to death zone. Back to death.
>> In the middle of nowhere. >> Sorry. It's just
one of those things. Chimmy Reviews is one of those people
and everybody does this to some extent, okay? It just depends
on how much you have had success with it in your life. how much
how many how much you've been surrounded by empathetic people.
But everybody will use like tragedy to get stuff to get like
um you know support from people or whatever. People do this,
okay? But Chibi Reviews is one of those people who excessively
does this on the internet who will take any tragedy in his life,
anything that bad that happens in his life and he will farm it
on the internet. And there is something kind of wrong about that.
Okay, there's something weird about that. You know, I don't talk
about [__] that happens with me very often. If I
do, it's like very very slight touches on it. Um, I try to keep
the personal stuff out of the stream entirely. You know what
I'm saying? Cuz I just I never want to have a group of people
who are going to hang out on stream who are here because they
think I'm like a victim the whole time. Do you know what I mean?
I don't I don't want to build a community around that. I just
I don't I want it to be fun. I want it to be light most of the
time. And I just don't want to I don't want people to show up
here because you're like a totally victim. It's just not the
kind of community you want. It's just it just feels wrong, man.
It just feels like wrong to me. Okay.
But Chibi Reviews does this with everything bad that happens
in his life like all the time. So
it's uh it's kind of rough, man.
>> Near water
and I drank
>> uh metaphorical metaphorical metaphorically. Okay.
and drank
just just sitting there drinking. >> Uh guys,
don't drink. Don't do drugs. It never brings good things. All
enjoyment will be short term. Highly recommend everybody to control
their vices. Never let those control you. Your life will be >> Dude,
can I get Can I get Marcus Aurelius in the frame again? This
guy I now I actually believe that he's reading meditations. Okay,
I do believe it. I don't believe he's going to actually apply
it to his life, but I do actually believe he might be listening
to an audio book of meditations. Okay,
this guy's going to This guy found a new
Okay, how do I explain this?
Tone is Sneo with 1,000th the comedic or cinematic talent. Okay,
Tekone's just Sneo. He just has none of the talent. He's got
one advantage over Sneo. He is white. Okay. But other than that,
he's just Sneo. He's just Sneo doing the exact Sneo move that
Sneo did 5 years ago or some [__] Okay. Four years
ago.
Yeah. Four years ago. It's literally It's just Sneo. Okay. >> Much
happier without alcohol and drugs >> or he's listening
to quote compilations vids on YouTube. He might be listening
to a YouTuber explain it to him. That's >> If you can find
the strength to do so.
We're like two We're two months tops away from Teto being like,
"Uh, you should clean your room. If your if your room is in disorder,
your life will be in disorder." Okay, if you you should clean
your room. Uh, if your life is chaos, your life will If your
room is chaos, your your life will be chaos. Okay, we're two
months away. Tops. I'd also like to say I had a similar similar
story
where uh I had a partner
and I allowed a
guy to come into my life. A guy who said he had nothing. a guy
who seek employment and >> oh sought employment but um
he's talking about the guy who cheated on him or cheat his wife
cheated on him with right I can't even remember the name
it's gone but frame frame cheated with te's manager so
this actually did kind of happen to Tone almost one to one not
even joking it really did >> so I employed him because
he told me that he needed it and you know people of my previous
association told me he was a good guy that he needed >> And
I employed him a you know
a near six figure salary
>> and then he your wife bro that's >> I took care
of this dude tried to make sure that his life was okay because
>> no cheated definitely cheated definitely cheated. Um,
Frame, while they were still married, Frame is like on in DMs
with people describing how she was like going on dates with this
guy, how they were sneaking out and going on dates.
Definitely cheated. Okay. Definitely >> because I was informed.
>> Um, cheated. And you could argue. So, if we ever watch
the infamous car clip, okay, the
>> conflict resolution god
>> in that clip that was before she had ever cheated on
him and he was clearly like kind of treating her like
I would never say Cruz or something. Yeah, something like that.
I would never say that that's like makes it okay to cheat. You
should leave your partner before you cheat. But he wasn't being
like a good partner obviously. Okay. >> person. Uh, and
then he my partner
and it was one of the biggest betrayals I've ever felt. Especially
because with this partner, I had already tried to leave six times
and they promised me they would change. They promised me they
would change and I gave them chance after chance after chance
after chance. And then to just [__] somebody else
while we were together is just insane. And it's like, oh, okay.
Well,
>> cheating on your abusive partner is morally neutral.
Um,
depends on the kinds of abuse.
It though I don't think it does. I think you can always just
leave. You can always just leave if you want.
You can always just leave.
I I still think that that has to be a thing on you.
It's not that Tech didn't deserve to be cheated on or something.
Okay?
It's not that. I'm not saying that. I'm saying you should never
for yourself think, "Okay, I'm going to cheat on this person.
I'm going to break my my marital vows because this guy's an [__]
You should think I'm going to well break my marital vows because
this guy's an in a different direction. [laughter] I'm sure I'm
sure Catholics would have a problem with what I'm saying, but
you you should get divorce or you should end the relationship
and say I'm moving on to something else. For yourself, not for
him, for yourself.
>> You know, it's hard to
get the trust back in people. But it does come back very slowly.
Um, but I too also
But then I had Eggy there and I thought, who's going to feed
Eggy if I kill myself? [snorts]
He's going to be hungry. He's going to be hungry. I got to feed
Eggy. But that's a story for another time. >> And I was
>> Do you notice he just does it? He just He just leans
into it. Yeah. I I'll tell you guys about the time I almost killed
myself. Okay. Yeah. I've I've you know, almost killed myself.
I I had some bad things happen. I'll tell you about it sometimes.
I hate Achy now. Is that his cat or I don't even know.
from death.
[snorts]
then suddenly
a police officer shows up.
Don't know how I was found,
but he shows up and
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. drove into the middle of nowhere
and I drank,
and drank. You >> need to weed these in once in a while.
from death.
Then suddenly,
>> oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. We need
to go further. We need to go further. Hold on. >> He saved
me at the last moment.
He did. And I come to find out
after all this, it was Nick Nicholas Light that was the one that
apparently
called a wellness check on me
and he he saved my life. He I I
he saved he saved my life.
>> To give some context on this, Nick actually made me
aware of this situation.
Um, and we were both frantically trying to
>> I thought about tweeting at this guy in some way or
another, but uh, he preemptively blocked me over the Techone
stuff. Okay, I was preemptively blocked. Also, followed by Dan
Saltman. Very interesting. But I was preemptively blocked by
this guy. Okay,
preemptively.
I've never tweeted at this guy before.
I was just autoblocked.
Up, man. to find out any way to contact Jimmy Chibi that we possibly
could. Um, and it was actually Nick's fiance that had the idea
for the wellness check. Um, so also huge W's to uh Nicholas's
fiance.
Uh, yeah, we were trying everything to get in contact with him,
barging. I It's funny because days later Chippy's like, "How
the did you get my number?" Um, but yeah, uh, huge W to Nick
and huge W to Nicholas's fiance for, uh, you know, preventing
a horrible disaster, a horrible tragedy that could have could
have happened. But I think what's really important right now
is that Chiby's at his lowest and in one year's time, I guarantee
you he's going to look back at this and be very thankful that
he did not go through with this cuz things will get better. Things
suck right now. But I'm telling you, >> I mean, I'll be
fair, okay? I don't know how things could get worse for Chibi
Reviews. Like, this has to be rock bottom. If he can survive
this, I can't imagine a set of circumstances that could play
out in like modernday America, first world country, that could
be any worse than this. Okay? [laughter] Like, like, if he lived
in 1938 Germany, maybe there could be circumstances that were
worse. Okay? But in in modern day America, I just can't imagine
how things possibly get worse than what he's described so far.
I'm sorry because we haven't even gotten to there's another cherry
on top of this. Okay. And it's hidden. Not hidden, but it's in
this tweet right here from yesterday. Okay. I just lost my fiance,
my best friend, and my entire friend group in 24 hours.
>> Thank you.
I do. I do. Just
Anyways, I
I get picked up and I'm going home.
Like, I'm free to go. Everything's fine.
And I knew I had to tackle the elephant in the room. I had to
go home and
sorry. Last night when we still thought his wife was like a total
hog. Okay. I was like, "Oh, so domestic abuse." But now the joke
doesn't work. Now that we've seen the picture of her, if this
is actually her, it doesn't really work as well. Like tackle
the elephant as in his wife. But
ah joke don't work no
I think you made the right choice.
Never forgive someone who's cheated on
>> I think I got to leave that up to the person who's cheated
on personally.
Um I think there are ways you could forgive it depending on what's
going on.
Like if there's some kind of betrayal from you or if you had
both been betraying each other's trust in some way and you both
decide you want to try again, there are like ways you could get
past it. If you were just trying your hardest in the relationship
and you you truly were if you could tell yourself, "I did everything
I could to make this relationship work and you get cheated on,"
then you should move on, okay? Because you are somebody who's
going to give a whole lot to this person and >> not get
anything back. If you did your best and you you weren't like,
you know, neglectful, abusive, you got cheated on, I do think
that's
Her hair could be coving her fat cheeks.
Okay, I do agree that that there could be h No, you see the edge.
I think the hair is behind the the event horizon of the cheek
here. Okay,
I don't think so. And she could be bigger than she looks, but
I and also this could be an old photo. I think this is like a
two or threey old photo possibly.
So, we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. >> And
if a woman can cheat on you with your best friend, no forgiveness.
They have no regret.
at all.
>> Never give second chances.
>> Crossing a boundary is one thing. You know, if they're
like off to when you don't want them off to that's like one
>> but
you're your best friend or any other human being. It's not a
human anymore, man. It's a demon. And way too many
>> um that's probably too simplistic.
I think there are ways that somebody could fall into, especially
a non-physical relationship where they're like emotionally cheating
with you with somebody else. There like ways that happens that
I think are understandable if
I, by the way, I'd never make fun of somebody who did like not
want to forgive someone who did that. But I think there are like
ways that people move in the world that you can forgive, right?
I don't know. I think I I disagree with this like super harsh
way of looking at it. um outside of maybe the physical act like
physically cheating with somebody else. I think that takes it
to another level as well >> will give other bad people
second chances because they don't want to be alone. [laughter]
>> And nowhere is that more evident than the streaming
space that people have no social lives. They have nothing else.
And so even if their streamer is outed as some sort of monster
like Techone, they don't care. They'll never ever move
I'm just glad bro got his ring back, you know, cuz like I know
those things are expensive, you know?
Don't cheat on somebody and then keep the ring. Absolutely not,
bro. >> I think the rule I'd have on this one is
you you keep the ring if it was a ring that was purchased. If
it's like a family heirloom ring, you give it back. If it's purchased,
it's given. It's a gift. It's given. That's the whole point of
proposal. If it's a family heirloom, out of respect, you give
it back. Usually the family heirlooms are not that expensive
anyway. Um, if it's a family heirloom kind of thing, which I
think a lot of people in the US do, you give that [__]
back. If it's like something that has been in their family for
a long time, you give that [__] >> I'm not
a perfect person. I make
I I know. I >> Not trying to make a joke out of it, but
Chibi Reviews, we all know you're evil, man. You you don't like
Boruto and you thought episode of episode one of Dondon was good.
>> People off
annoy them. >> We're going to we're going to get into a
lot more of exactly how he people off within this stream. Okay,
we'll get into a lot of it. Now, I will be honest, he does not
piss people off in the precise way Teto people off. Tetto's like
a legitimately harmful person who goes after people like a lot
and who has, you know, been found, you know, likely to have committed
assault and stalking, you know, or there's a reasonable likelihood
he committed assault and stalking. There's a lot of things to
dislike about TeeOne that are very tangible and very real. With
Chibi Reviews, it's a lot more there's some stuff like that,
but it is a lot more just the essence of this person is like
actually annoying. It's a lot harder to defend the hatred for
Chibi Reviews. Okay, I'll be real. It's there. It's there. It
exists. There are reasons. It's just not quite the same. So,
if you're expecting like me to explain to you how Chibi Reviews
like a whole bunch of people, you're gonna be shocked. Are you
a Chibi Review supporter? I am not. I am not. Super D-100. So,
I'm sorry if you thought this was going to be a W Chibi Review
stream. It is not. It is not. Okay.
>> Hold this for a while. And I'm going to tell you right
now, if anyone wants to pull any stupid games, you're going to
win stupid prizes. That's all I'm going to say. Well, I will
say now going one. >> Oh, I started the wrong video. But
yes, there is that very cringe moment. Uh oh. Uh oh. Shut it
down. Just link something said this is the pick Miz doesn't want
anyone to know about. NO, NO, MIZ. [screaming] MIZ,
THAT'S RAPE TONE. MIZ, DON'T DO IT. DON'T DO IT, MIZ. THAT'S
RAPE. NO, MIZ, NO.
NO. NO. NO.
OKAY, it's fine. But
my anyways, after she after she left, I
didn't want anyone.
>> This this is the absolute >> I wanted to find
someone. >> Not really.
I go to my gaming friend group that I've known
just as long
as my best friend that
my my
cheated with.
>> Jesus. I talk with them
and
they straight up they admit to me they don't care basically
what my used to be best friend did
they prefer gaming with him and I thought these guys were my
friends I I did >> so he went to his friend group his like
gaming friend group and said guys this guy cheated he's my best
friend of 10 years this guy cheated on on this guy cheated with
my wife my wife cheated on with him.
You got to I I can't be around him anymore. And they're like,
"Man, that sucks that you're going to have to find another gaming
group. That sucks that you're going to have to find another like
Marvel rival stack, man." Yeah, you play Spider-Man, bro. You
play Spider-Man. You mean Black Panther and Spider-Man. None
of us wanted you here in the first place. Okay. The only reason
we let YOU IN IS CUZ THAT GUY was cool. You're a loser. That
guy was cool. You think we're gonna kick him out of the group?
He's our tank man. He's literally the best tank in the group.
We're not kicking him out. Get the [__] out of here.
Get the [__] out of here. Yeah, that's that's wild.
Okay, that's that's wild. >> And they straight up they
admit to me they don't care basically
what my used to be best friend did.
They prefer gaming with him. And I thought these guys were my
friends. I I did.
and they more or less they just care about being with him and
they didn't care about everything. They're completely okay with
>> Like that's crazy. >> And so
more or less
I lost my whole friend group,
my best friend. like being told that yeah, okay, this guy may
have like cheated uh with your wife,
but like he's a better Black Widow in Marvel Rivals is insane.
I think the biggest red pilling moment that people will have
in
Okay, am I crazy? Am I crazy or do I
I'm not joking.
I feel like when I hear like that, maybe I'm just Maybe I'm just
way too egotistical. I feel like there's a chance TeeOne was
watching my reaction. I feel like there's a chance Tech saw my
reaction somewhere.
Like I I immediately took it to Marvel Rivals because I've been
playing Marvel Rivals. Marvel Rivals is not the big game right
now. The big game right now is well it was Deadlock and it was
Overwatch. Although Marvel Rivals did time a patch and some people
are playing Marvel Rivals as well, but
I know he monitors the haters and I'm just sitting here like
did he listen to me talk about this or >> their lives is
understanding that like everybody on this earth is
straight up like everybody on this earth there are so many on
this earth it's crazy and I think that will lead you down the
red pill pipeline
>> that basically
Huh? There's so many on this earth. Well, if you can't beat them,
join them. That's another Marcus Aurelius moment. When in Rome,
do as the Romans do. I actually think that's from the Bible or
something, but it's fine.
>> One second. I'll be right back. >> There was moments
where he was hurting
years ago with CO and I gave him money for he could have bills
paid and his family wouldn't have to worry. I I cared for him.
He he was he said he was moving down here in
a few months
and he I now know why
>> he was trying to his wife. It's horrible, man. It's
terrible.
Absolutely terrible, bro. >> He He wanted to. What I will
say, I lost a lot.
I lost a lot, >> dude.
I now that's kind of rough. Okay. If he helped this guy out monetarily
and the guy came down to his wife. I don't think the guy was
moving towards him to the to Chiby's wife.
I just can't see that being the case, man.
That that seems like a stretch. >> I didn't
>> Chibby tweeted 40 minutes ago. Hold on. Important tweet.
Okay. Important tweet.
Seeing how happy it would make my haters if I died. I live out
of spite. Oh, that's not great.
That's not great. That's not going to last you very long. I suggest
finding a reason to live that's not spite, okay? Cuz the spite
will burn you out. I'm just saying find a reason to live that's
not spite cuz it will burn out and then Hey. Okay,
dude.
Also seeing what I've seen today, I'm going to double down too
out of spite. Before I go any further, to those that reached
out, I promise to respond and go through it all later. I noticed
a lot a lot of panel recognition from certain groups today or
two today. Always the party of acceptance people. Multiple flags
are a big indication, too. Certain usage of gifts as well. Animals
pretending to be human with subpar intelligence.
All my enemies are communists and furries. Every single one of
my dude, no way. No way.
Did I just see the next line of this post? There's no chance
that he followed up with, "I'm also pro ICE and I think illegal
immigrants should not be in my country.
me. Kill me. Actually, actually killing me. Actually, killing
me. Actually, killing me. Actually, killing me. Actually, killing
me.
H I He There's no way he's already at the stage where he references
to [__] but you know he would. You know, he would.
Okay,
dude. I am also pro ICE and I think illegal immigrants should
not be in my country. the the
degenerate to conservative influencer pipeline has to be totally
shut down until we can figure out what the is going on. Okay?
What the hell is going
If you are, you cannot be on Twitter also shilling conservative
politics. It cannot happen. I will not allow it to happen anymore.
Okay?
absolutely unacceptable that all of these random
who are total just total freaks who love kids are all going to
come out here and show liberal politics. If you're going to show
politics, go show progressive politics, okay? Something that
actually thinks maybe you have a chance at living. Do not do
not come out here. You are as embarrassing, okay, as every single
liberal who has ever or every single progressive who has ever
had a bad interaction with a migrant and then gone, "Oh, actually,
I think all illegal im immigrants shouldn't be here, right? You
are the the exact like leopards ate my face person." All of these
people think chibby reviews, every single person who's pro ICE
actually thinks you should be put in a wood chipper. Okay? If
you ever talked to them about what you actually like in this
world, they would be like wood chipper for you immediately. Okay?
Come on, bro. Come on, dog.
Stop. You're You're being super fake. This is a total performance.
It's a total LAR. Be real for two seconds. Okay. Absolutely wild.
Why is he mad at migrants? They didn't [__] his wife.
Do you know that, Orange Kush? Do you know that for a fact? You
don't know. You don't know what the circumstances of his friend
for 10 years or friend of 10 years are. Maybe that guy was Maybe
that guy's a dreamer. Okay. Maybe Obama kept him in this country.
But for Obama, keeping the dreamers in America,
chippy reviews would never have been cocked. Okay? And he's sworn
he's sworn total allegiance to the Republican party as a
I however do not think they are perfect. If you hate me and want
me dead for that stance, that won't change my mind. Now, feel
free to spaz out in my comments below and call me a racist, a
a loser, or whatever for a common sense. For a common sense takes
having a hard time talking directly. You must have been taking
some of that. You must have been drinking some of that alcohol
again. Okay, feel free to call me a racist, a loser or whatever
for a common sense takes.
All your interactions have made me tremendous amounts of money
spreading my name around. So, hope that ped you off all off so
much. With that, I bid you farewell for tonight. The lollycon
to conservative grifter pipeline
strikes again. Obviously, dude, it's just so
it's just so crazy how predictable it is. Like, it shouldn't
be this predictable, should it? Should it be this predictable?
It really shouldn't. Like, how how it doesn't piss me off. The
more people to make fun of in the future, the f uh fun of this
future statistic, the better. Oh, the more people to make fun
of this future statistic, the better. Sure. Um, what am I trying
to think here? So, it is one of those things.
It's not quite the Nusra thing. It's almost the Nusra thing.
Not quite. Okay. Not quite. Like all my enemies gathering one
place. It's a good thing because these guys were already on the
same team. They just have collectively grifted, right? It's very
goofy.
Never thought I'd see it.
Okay, back to the Teto reaction.
>> wild stuff. >> Fiance. I b I lost my whole social
circle basically just gone.
What really hurts? Best friend in 10
He knew everything.
He knew my
my life story. He He had I thought he had my back. He >> You
know what the worst thing is? The people that you let in the
most are the people who are able to hurt you the most. And
Like I feel like that's a real sentiment, right? That you would
have trusted this person a lot. that probably this is a betrayal
of trust that few people could recover from. Truly, I don't think
that's weird to say. Now, you'd have to know both sides of the
story here for sure.
Did Marcus say that? No. I'm just saying it's pretty
he had his wife's Well, yeah. No, actually, he did have your
wife's back. Your your fiance's back. That's true. What I unfortunately
am I'm going to predict. I I bet you the fiance and the best
friend of the friend group are going to like try to like ruin
Chiby's life on Twitter and say some crazy ass that immediately
tells me Chibi told Teeone about some he did. Cuz here's the
thing. Let's just be real. We said this last night. Let's just
be totally
This is not a normal reaction. Okay.
Um, you can have I've been in this situation where the guy that
everybody likes in the friend group [__] like somebody
else in that friend group [__] like uh the girlfriend
of somebody else in that friend group. This is not the normal
reaction. Like even if you're not the most popular dude in that
friend group, this is not the normal reaction. >> $3 you
find the girl of your dreams and the whole time she be cheating
on you. >> She do be cheating like that. She be cheating
all the time. True. Thank you very much, Ruben. Ruben, I appreciate
it, man. Oh god.
This is not the normal reaction. And this makes me think there's
more to the story that he is not laying out here. Obviously,
I think this is pretty much everybody universally agreed on this
right after these tweets were released. Like, okay, tell me what
you did. Cuz when I hear the friend group took the side of the
cheaters,
given everything you've said, I'm like, "Yeah, you did some.
You had to have done some shit." I assumed he actually like hit
his wife or also cheated on his wife or
I don't even know what else would be there. And now Teton's laying
it out like oh these guys are going to try to ruin his life.
Or are they going to come out and say that well actually this
is what happened and Chibi Reviews has totally misrepresented
it.
And I think these videos might him in the end because if they
do come out and like lay out all this then it's just going to
be who can who can lay out everybody's like private business
the best.
So doing this video where you're revealing all this stuff like
all this angst
this only works against you. Okay.
I want to remind you that people like dug up this guy's like
grave, his brother's grave
to just harass him. >> Did they actually go and dig up
his grave? I thought they just posted it. They actually go dig
up the grave. Did they vandalize the grave? >> And listen
guys,
>> Cuz as much as that's like totally crazy and I totally
disavow it, I also
can't help but like stand in awe of the hater energy. Okay. that
it would require to go with like somebody's corpse because you
hate a guy on the internet because he had bad takes about Boruto.
Okay. The hater energy required. I can't help but stand back
in awe of that while totally disavowing it. Obviously, it's totally
>> Should be like lollies.
Yeah. Does that mean people should try to like >> I mean
I don't Are you which side of this aisle are you on? Techone.
Techone. Why don't you go ask some of your guys in the conservative
gun tuber sphere what they think of lollycons? Hey, what should
we do to lollycons? Brandon Herrera like locks in his
his uh his AR-15. I guess I there's probably a better gun. His
AR-15 and just like fires a bunch of bunch of guns down or fires
a bunch of bullets downrange. That's what we should do to people
like that. Okay.
No, not an AK. I was thinking um what is it? An MG250. What's
the What's the heavy the
the Rambo machine gun? It's like an MG250. No, MG. What is it?
What is it? What is the Rambo gun? MG249. M249.
I was like not that far off. One letter and one number.
Yeah.
Brandon Herrera like locks one of these down down range. Okay.
Goes, "This is what we should do to people like that. This is
what we should be doing to people like that." Okay. Does Teto
not know what side he's on? They don't like over in the conservative
side, buddy.
Like, is the guy a little weird?
>> Okay. Brandon Herrera made an AK-47. That's a 50 caliber.
Yeah, that sounds
>> But does that mean we should be digging up his brother's
grave? It's like, no, it's insane.
>> It's like actually [__] insane. >> It
is totally insane. >> There for me with >> It is
totally insane and way too far.
It is totally insane. Way too far.
And the fact that they did this over an anime beef is totally
crazy to me, too. >> Times of being harassed
and I viewed him like a brother. He He does that.
>> that's me. That's me with the music.
>> I [sighs]
I was in a dark place and I've had a lot of dark thoughts all
day. All >> this guy's making this video fresh, too.
Like this is like like four hours after a guy is contemplating
and makes this video. Feel bad because like when I talked about
like my divorce, I was like, "Oh, bro, this video is going to
bang." Like, "How do I clickbait it?" Like that's probably the
most sociopathic I've ever been where I was like, "All right,
I need a one out of 10 video. I need to get back on." >> No,
that's like part for the course for Tech. No, it's like part
for the course, buddy. Unironically, part for the course for
you, >> YouTube algorithm.
How do I How do I make this video? I know. I'll call it I lost
her. I actually copied Mizg's video on Maya. >> The I lost
her video because that video like popped the off of him. >> Like
I'll be real. I was like so detached from reality cuz like all
I really cared about was like anime girls at that point. I was
like ah it
hey [laughter] I lo Hey, the video banged too. The video banged.
Hey, shout out to the trilogy on uh on Twitter that I lost her
loss.
I spent $3,000 on Gotcha Wipers,
you know? But like I had already like come to terms. I was like,
"All right,
is what it is. I don't really give a [__] that much.
This is a fresh one, man. This is this is this is hard. This
is [__] brutal, bro." >> Last night, >> yeah,
horrible time to make a video. Literally just the worst possible
time to make the video. Absolutely not shocking whatsoever that
Teone's a sociopath, psychopath, whatever the [__]
we want to call him here. Okay, pretty clear, pretty obvious.
I just I just want to clickbait my divorce, man. My divorce,
I didn't even care anymore. I didn't give a I just want to clickbait
it. Also, guys, feel really bad for me about how I was after
my divorce,
right? >> I have. >> You can tell he really loved
her.
can you I'm going to be honest, guys. This is one of the hardest
moments for me in my my entire life. But >> and he's he's
probably right.
But I think you should take comfort in knowing that um as hard
as this is as a man, there's going to be harder moments.
Hey man, I I thought the hardest moment of my life would be losing,
you know, my cat burger's life.
And then, you know, day after day, I realized, damn, the pain
I realized ain't [__] to what I'm dealing with now.
And you know what? I got through that. I'm going to get through
this. And realizing how much better I've become after every painful
experience is something beautiful. Genuinely, the best men are
forged by pain. And that's the truth. I've
like I guess I've I've told you guys many times if you've watched
my content, one of the only joys
in my life I've had over the years
is making content.
>> Wow. You know, you'd think you'd think maybe it was
like his relationship with his girlfriend, wife, or whatever,
but no, it's just been making content. One of the only things
that brought him joy in the entire world, not not the relationship,
just making content. Gay, >> get back on that grind, man.
>> Get back on that grind. >> The one thing
that's never that's never caused me problems. One thing
>> Hold on. >> Get back on that grind, man.
>> Get back on that grind. >> One thing >> is
the one thing that's never caused me problems. That's not true.
You've definitely talked about your love of lollies and that's
definitely caused you problems. I would just say
ah he's saying a lot of like I've only ever loved one thing in
this life and none of it is the fiance that left. >> It's
never that's never caused me problems. I just
I did lose so much. I she was he was sending her
and just the
>> the what? Wait, what?
>> Hold on. Listen again. >> He was sending her >> He
was sending her [clears throat]
>> And just the
What was the hard K sound there that he was going to say? I like
I'm sorry. There's very few things that I could think.
Is it What's in his mind right
What's in his mind right now that he is like getting disturbed
by? I'm starting to think that
possibly he got by a Boruto fan. Okay. His his best friend. He
didn't realize that that guy was very statistically likely to
be a Boruto fan. Okay. I'm just I'm just saying.
>> Crazy. Insane. >> I'm pretty hurt, guys. I'm not
going to >> Nobody blames you, man. We all get it. >> I
don't know what's going to happen or anything. Hi, >> you're
going to get back on the saddle.
>> I, by the way, I totally wouldn't care if,
how do I put this? If this guy had like DM' me for help or something,
maybe not him specifically because some baggage there, but like
if this guy was in DMs, okay,
I would have no problem saying the things Tech is saying to him.
I feel tremendously manipulated by him making like his main channel
content out of this. Okay. It just feels weird and
Why is Teone talking about this dude? This is one of Tech's friends
who is a part of like the to conservative Grifter pipeline. Okay,
with Teone. Tech's building a pipeline and every single
on Twitch is eventually going to become a conservative grifter.
Okay, they're going to get that entire pipeline of guys coming
over. He has to milk it, I guess. It just feels gross to me,
man. It just feels gross. I I totally I could have empathy for
somebody I really dislike in this exact situation if they weren't
trying to publicly milk the situation. You know what I'm saying?
Like I could really dislike somebody and if they like let's say
this guy messaged me directly and he said, "Hey, I'm going through
some stuff right now. If you could like lay off me on Twitter,
I'd appreciate it." I'd probably respect that. Unless it was
like an obvious overt lie, I'd probably respect that. You know
what I'm saying? But when it's this public video that he does
talking through this stuff, I'm like, "Bro, this is inappropriate.
This is actually not not appropriate at all. I don't know what
else to say, man. >> You're gonna get back to grinding
and then one year later, you're not even going to remember the
bitch."
That's the truth. Currently, Chibi, I'm just being real. You
most likely thought of this woman as your world. In a year, you're
going to forget.
That's the truth.
Life goes on.
Get in the gym.
Read some books. I recommend right now.
>> Okay. I will He's going to recommend the meditations,
isn't he? Um I will say
one thing you should never do that feels like a very easy thing
to do, something you should do is if you get in a a breakup,
you shouldn't have to. Or I've never I don't know if I've quite
been in the situation chibies in. I don't think I ever have.
I've been in like somewhat similar things, but never like explicitly,
you know, a partner who's been cheating on you. Um,
but what I would say is if you feel like you have to denigrate
the other person or make them less to feel good about yourself,
never do that. Okay? You should have to build yourself up so
that you could find somebody better, you should never have to
tear the other person down. That's just like a spiral down into
like totally total like personal destruction. You shouldn't have
to tear that person down. You shouldn't have to say that [__]
that stupid [__] she's like awful. She's the worst.
Actually, I I hated her all. You should never have to do that.
You should say, I did care about that person. That person was
awesome. I'm going to be better. I'm going to be too good for
that person. That's the only way you like pull yourself out of
[__] like that cuz then you start actually doing
things to improve your situation. You stop this spiral downwards
into negativity. Okay, that's the gym thing is not even bad advice,
okay? It should be you're building yourself up in some way. Should
never be tearing this other person down and making yourself feel
better that they're gone. It should be making yourself feel like
actually they there's probably a reason they cheated or something
along. I don't know if I could quite do that if that happened
to me, but there's it's like actually there's probably a reason
the breakup happened and I need to be better. That's what you
need to think. Okay, that's the only way >> Marcus Aurelius
meditations.
>> [__] Kelly.
Oh, we're on Twitch. I was I was very close there. I was
your emotions because you're becoming a stoic and the meditations
is an awesome book. Thank you, Tech, for the recommendations.
Um,
oh, that that went.
Okay. I wish the grift wasn't so obvious is what I would say.
I just wish the grift was like slightly less obvious, it would
be less offensive. Like, if you do if you weren't griing by assuming
everybody in your audience is a complete utter, as valid and
grounded as that assumption may be, I would feel less embarrassed
or less angry about it. But you are grifting as if everybody
in your audience is a total [__] and it depresses
me. Okay. >> It's a book I recommend to everybody to read.
It will change your It will change your worldview.
Life goes forward. Hey, the reality is
women are like buses.
Okay?
You just get on to the next one.
It really is. Now, eventually you're going to find one that feels
right and that's going to be the one that's with you for life.
But in reality, hey,
yep, you found out they weren't who they said they were. Okay,
next,
don't sweat it, right? Like what you thought was a fivestar got
nerfed to a
They're not meta anymore, man.
Go to the next one, bro. There's a new banner
>> Yeah. Like trying to make that person like not special,
that's a way you like denigrate yourself in addition to everybody
else, right?
Community note. I noticed that there's fights over the community
notes on that. I've seen it had a community note before I went
live and then I went live. There was no note and now there's
a note again.
Is the note just that one? There's only one passport. I think
it's just one passport or something
or chank. I'm not even going to click on the tweet. Anyway, I
think I think this is the way you like stay depressed to be honest
with you is you have to like denigrate this other person. You
have to make this person worse. Then what are you going to do
by the way? All all you have to think about there is what are
you going to do if that person finds somebody who's like better
than you in some way? You're going to obsess because they're
supposed to be bad. They're supposed you've told yourself that
they're then they start dating like a millionaire or something,
a billionaire or something. What are you going to do? You're
like your mind is broken, right? The only way for you out of
that pit is up. Okay. For yourself. Has nothing to do with that
other person. >> There's a new better Hey, get the new
one. Way better. It's like a totally lazy way to to try to get
over a relationship and it's never going to work long term. If
you have to make everybody around you bad because they don't
like you anymore. You'll just constantly spiral on it. You'll
be a weak person. >> You ride enough buses eventually.
>> And I haven't even had to read meditations to figure
that out. >> You'll become the bus driver. You'll be all
right. >> Really don't.
The future's uncertain right now. I have
I have no idea. I am positive in one year's time Chibi will look
back at this and laugh.
Genuinely,
he'll be like, "Man, that was [__] up. Anyways,
I got this new chick straight up." Everybody thinks that these
relationships are like the end of their >> Oh, that is
another effect that happens. There's there's something that happens
which is particularly up like a thing in human nature. And you
know, we could get into why people feel like they're barely treading
water in life. I don't really care to right now. But especially
when people are not doing well themselves, if they see you really
struggling, people will avoid you. And it's a really awful thing
in human nature that like if somebody can't take care of themselves
and they see someone else struggling, they will move away from
you. And so sometimes when you end up in situations like this,
if you're particularly like vulnerable and not doing well, people
will just go, "Oh, that guy's like that's the sad sack. Avoid
him. That's the sad sack. Avoid him." Right? No, no, no. This
is everybody if they're really struggling dingling us. Now, maybe
it's worse than white people cuz white people are particularly
atomized. There's not a lot of um solidarity there.
Good analogy is the broken down car. Sure. Maybe. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Evil Johnny Bravo. Yes. But it is it is one
of those things where if you are making positive improvements,
people will notice that and they won't avoid
That's what you got to do. Can't can't let yourself be totally
dissuaded, totally destroyed. Just got to keep improving. Got
to keep being better than you were the day before.
Supposedly, Chibi may be a fan of NTR, which also makes this
so much funnier if true. Well, I saw somebody saying that. I
saw people doing that and then I saw Dickers was going through
tweets, the NTR tweets. I didn't think they were very funny.
Like, they didn't seem very funny or like that they made a point
very effectively. But we could go find >> Give me a second.
>> Bro, that [__] wasn't worth a damn, bro.
If she's a cheater, and you know what the worst thing is? This
is the only time you caught her.
That definitely been going on for a while. There ain't no way
you caught him on the first time. So [__] it. She
was a piece of [__] You up. Don't let this win by
seeing you sweat.
The best revenge and everybody needs to know this. The best revenge
is living a good life. Show her she didn't matter. Show her you're
going to succeed in spite of them. Who cares, bro? I
again and this I understand why Tone's here because he needs
to do this with uh Pinkchu. I guarantee you that a bunch of his
friends one of the things that would have affected Tecton's ego
a lot is the fact that Pingchu was very successful actually became
like totally mainstream massively successful
while they were apart
right that would have [__] with Teone.
So he has he has this attitude and watching her like absolutely
blow up like build her career up massively totally blow the up
away from him that had to have [__] with him. So
he should know particularly like how how bad this is as a way
to approach life. Okay. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Evil Johnny Bravo.
It's like people are just thinking and even the best revenge
you can get on people like an ex it is it is unironically it's
just true the good life thing. That's the best revenge you can
get.
Um, sometimes you can blend a good life with actually getting
revenge, and that's cool. But if you prioritize, basically the
revenge has to be like a an easy side quest you find along the
way. If you try to just get revenge, you'll never build yourself
up enough to get the proper revenge. Okay. The revenge has to
be like I, you know, I have all this clout. I have like all this
um, not even clout necessarily. I'm just really happy. And this
person like basically tried to ask for like a recommendation
for a job where I work and I get to be like, "No, I don't think
so. No, I don't think so."
Right? That's It has to be like a in the- moment decision. It's
like a side quest. Easy side quest. Read meditations. Seek revenge.
Yeah, cuz Aurelius was so into revenge. Did he even read the
book? Well, probably not. Here, we'll we'll keep listening. >> Definitely
been going on for a while. There ain't no way you caught him
on the first time. So, [__] it. She was a piece of
[__] You up. Don't let this win by seeing you sweat.
The best revenge, and everybody needs to know this, the best
revenge is living a good life.
Okay. I mean, that is his that is his um overall point. >> Show
her she didn't matter. Show her you're going to succeed in spite
of them. Who cares, bro? >> So, this isn't like terrible
advice, but it is focused on her, right? I'm telling you, that's
not what people need to hear. That like a the best way to get
revenge on her, if you have that negative motivation, it's bad,
too. It is true, but you need to want to you need to want that
for yourself. >> Get to the gym, man. Doesn't necessarily
have to include the gym, by the way. Go for a walk every day.
It doesn't have to be the gym. You don't have to get swole to
be happy. In fact, if you start driving that direction, you're
going to find that you'll get like body dysmorphia or something.
Okay? Like, the gym isn't bad, but the gym isn't required. Physical
activity is required, but the gym is not a thing that you need.
Okay? It's it happens to be something that works quite well,
I think, but it's not something that's necessarily required.
Not not like bedrotting all the time. That is totally >> I
however am making this video to try to [clears throat] some degree
to cement my thoughts in stone
to be able to process them in my own way
to be able to try to move past this just
day. I I I just >> Dude, it's so funny that he like drops
an AirPod here or something. I think that's what happens. like
drops one of his AirPods. Okay. Like, hold on. Is he wearing
it when he does it? You can hear it hit the floor like when he
knocks on the floor. >> It sounds like an AirPod to me.
>> Day I I
>> Boom beeps. He knocks something onto the
I just >> This is how much God hates this guy right now.
Just so we're clear. Okay. He just knocked something onto the
floor. It's clearly like a hard floor, a hard surface floor.
He goes to lean down and he doesn't even find the thing somewhere
on his hard surface floor wherever it
>> He looks
then he like adjusts to look somewhere else and then he
looks somewhere else
and he's still looking and then he doesn't find it and he realizes
he scratches his face and then he realizes I guess I'm like I
guess I just go back to talking.
That's how rough the day is right now for him. Okay. Did you
drop his phone? It was something beside his phone. That's why
I think it's the AirPods or something. Okay.
Like Like literally, he looked in every direction and it has
disappeared. That's the day he's having. >> I'm going to
be honest with you guys. I I don't know what I will do.
I There's two ways I either a I don't make videos for a while.
>> No, [__] that. >> Or
I just make videos and I try to black
>> Black hole, baby. black hole everything and just >> black
hole. Push through it. >> Keep
moving. >> Hey, punch through. >> I've heard advice
like that somewhere. I don't really want to say where. [__]
up. >> We'll see.
>> What I will say though, I thank everyone that's been
supportive.
to those out there, you know who you are. You >> Here's
what I'm going to say, and I think we've seen enough.
Chibby,
there are so many people that [__] on you.
Push through. Don't let them see you sweat. I promise you in
a year's time, you're going to look back at this and you're not
even going to give a
get to the gym
right now.
>> I mean, he let us see him sweat. That's the problem.
He let us see him sweat. He gave all of the information away
that could with him. I don't I don't know what to tell you, man.
Like this is this is unfortunately behind the eightball.
Somebody should have been with him. He should never have posted
that video.
Like there's just no reason to ever post that video. That video
was a crazy post. Okay. That you're like you just get home from
the hospital after wanting to kill yourself and then there's
nobody. It's unfortunate that there's nobody there who could
step in and go, "No, you're not making a video right now. You
got to show me a script. You want to publish a video? You got
to show me a script for a video." Okay? You show me a script
that you're going to read, we can talk about it. You want to
go live and just like rant about getting cheated on? No. Nope.
Nope. Nope. >> Go to the gym right now.
>> Push through. Get in shape. >> Sadly, it's dudes
like this that always get cheated on. >> Get stronger.
Get faster. Get smarter.
Okay. And realize this woman you loved wasn't real.
It was the idea of her that existed in your brain. And the reality
has been shattered. The genjutsu is over. The illusion is gone.
You didn't lose anyone. You didn't lose the woman you love because
the woman you love never existed.
It was the idea of her because the woman you love would have
never cheated on you. The moment they did that, you realize your
version of them was exactly that, just a version and not someone
who actually exists. So, push through. Get to the gym. >> This
is This sounds like all the right advice, right? It sounds like
all the right advice. It's the standard advice that everybody
gives you. Um, actually, they sucked the whole time. Go to the
gym. It's like I
I I understand why they give it. Maybe it helped them get through
something. I kind of understand why you give it, but it's not
the key to happiness at all. Like, they're selling it. It's just
not. It's not. It's not. Um, probably probably you made some
bad decisions in your relationship. Probably you do need to look
at yourself. Even if it was you who got cheated on, right? probably
there were some problems there. Probably you might even know
that some of these problems have existed in other places. I would
say, you know, get some therapy, talk through some of these things
with somebody who's willing to push you on, you know, some of
your instead of you always painting yourself as the perfect victim.
Find people who don't treat you like the perfect victim like
like a victim all the time would be my first piece of advice.
>> Oh, hold on. Ruben Ruben donation. >> Ruben donated
victim victim. I need to >> logic text dad never existed.
Your dad in your The dad in your mind was never somebody who
would rap Teone. The father in your mind was never
uh Yeah, he was though. Oh, [__] Never mind. Techone's
dad existed all the time. That was not even outside the norm
of expectation for his dad. Okay. Techn's dad obviously exists
even for Tee. So, um what Chippy Reviews needs to find is somebody
who doesn't um validate this behavior repeatedly. That's what
he needs to find where like they don't validate the behavior
where he is just the victim all the time. That's the first thing
I would say is is if there's somebody who doesn't just treat
you like you are the victim always that doesn't validate this
cuz I see you doing it to the point that you go on a live not
a live stream but uh the point that you post a video that night
of you being a victim, right? Find somebody who's not going to
validate that who's not maybe the worst person ever. And then
yeah, therapy usually a therapist will do that for you. They'll
actually ask questions that unpeel or sort of like peel the onion
there and help you figure out that you're not always a victim,
right? And then do something positive for yourself.
Could be the gym. Not going to say it's not the gym. It's not
cringe just cuz tech don't say it, but there's a lot of other
things, too. >> Focus on yourself. Focus on your content.
You will find someone else. You will. And you'll be much happier.
Okay. Number one thing, quit gooning.
Okay? You're going to want to goon. Stop gooning. Push through.
Stay strong. Get, you know, push through. Get strong. Work
I'm starting to feel like the people on the other side of the
uh, like I do think the degenerates, the overly the heavy-handed
degenerates on the internet have a problem. It's like
anybody who's like the Xanderhal of Gooning or the Hunter Avalone
of Gooning needs to off. Actually, you just don't have good advice.
the people who are like total degenerates online and they go
to like the don't goon I'm actually going to church and and never
goon and all the [__] you get the out of here okay
I don't need your opinion you're actually a total [__]
loser it's like the same as politics if you go from one side
of the gooning spectrum all the way to the other overnight
no off don't make content about it don't talk about it get the
out of here rip Tom I think Tom I don't think he like you could
argue he's like that because he used to like Destiny content
which is obviously some DJ Gen stuff,
right?
But it's just like the stop gooning thing. I I know you're saying
that because you got a problem with it.
I know that's why you're saying it >> now. Drink water.
Stop gooning and improve yourself, man. You got this. Never give
up. And realize all these people who you thought had your back
don't. But now you know who does.
Now you know who does. And that is so
>> Tone just needs any allies he can get. I I truly believe
that. Okay. Doesn't matter who they are. Tecton will ally with
he'll ally with anybody. Turns out he's got a lot of relationships.
So that's where he's getting his support from originally like
right now. Okay. Who's a guy who's like overtly protect who's
not
Can we Can we name someone? Is there a single person? I'm trying
to think of somebody who's overtly protect who's not
legal mindset. No. Tactical Templar. No. Uh Nicholas Light. No,
this guy. Chippy Reviews. No. Dan Saltman. Uh, is Dan Saltman
like an overt techone supporter? I feel like no. I feel like
not anymore.
Hard to say. Very, very hard to say.
>> And recognize what you saw on them and other people
and avoid waste of time like those. >> Pegasus. Well, again,
Twitch is causing issues here. >> You got this. Lock in.
Goon less. Find a good woman. Get to the gym. You got this, man.
>> Ah, yeah. Okay. Okay. Goon less. Goon less, guys. Just
goon less and we're all fine.
Just goon less.
Wow. Okay. Well, we are going to we're going to continue on with
the Jibby reviews content because there is more. Okay.
That was just that was just the techone part. Now we can finish
the miz Now we can finish the miz clip. Okay. You know what?
Do we want to start it from the beginning again? It's only 2
minutes. for my fiancé.
>> Just in case people were rolling in late, we'll start
it from there. >> Cheating on me with my best friend of
>> YEAH. [screaming]
All right.
Nice.
Woo.
Good for her. Good for her. Congratulations, lady. Congratulations.
You finally moved on. Get the hell out of there. Good job. Honestly,
that's a good friend to you, dude. Because you obviously didn't
want a fiance because she's not 13 years old. So, good for her.
Good friend and good fiance. I'm proud of them. Good job, guys.
Good job all around. Good applause. Good applause. Honestly,
this calls for a celebration, chat. Another cost of tech. Let's
take a drink, shall we?
And drank. And I was
from death. [snorts] Then suddenly
a police officer shows up.
Don't know how I was foul.
He saved me at the last moment.
He did.
I don't believe this story for one minute. I'm sorry, man. I
just do not believe
this story. I don't believe anything you're saying, man. I just
don't believe it. It just doesn't It's just so stupid. >> This
guy's a weirdo. He hangs out with weirdos. His whole thing is
and these kids are weird. He's a weirdo. I have no sympathy for
this man whatsoever. I have >> Who is this guy
like that? >> No sympathy for
now. Misgif is going a little far there. I don't necessarily
think this means you are a danger to children. I do think it's
super high
super huge red flag. Massive red flag.
Again, it to me
I look at this a lot more favorably if you just shut the up about
it, right? If you if you like like this stuff or something and
you never mention it to anybody, you just keep that alone in
like all your other fetishes in a in a box that you don't talk
about publicly. To me, I'm like, okay, you show some self-control,
I believe you could show self-restraint if a situation presented
itself where you could, you know, play out your fantasies in
the real world. If you have no self-control, if you have to talk
about this stuff all the time and fight for it all the time in
public, I'm like, I don't know about you, man. I don't know about
you, man. That makes me feel uncomfortable. >> Was the
one that apparently
called a wellness check on me
and he >> Wow. Nicholas Light. Good job, dude.
Good job. Nice.
>> Okay, that was the Miz clip. Now, without further ado,
we could go into a couple of these Chibi Reviews videos over
the years. All right. Okay. We watched Did we watch this one?
Yeah, we finished the Boruto community one. Okay, we finished
that. Now, in November of 2024, I'm getting married in two years
of daily uploads. So, I think this is when he proposed to his
current girlfriend. My family is in danger and my account was
hacked. So, his account got hacked and I believe he says his
account got hacked and it posted some
Uh, some other people think that he accidentally posted some
[__] and then said his account got hacked. Okay.
So, we'll we'll take a look. We'll watch the >> On one
hand, I now have enough evidence to really press criminal charges
and get like Homeland Security, cyber security and stuff, and
even the FBI involved. I've talked with a few people that have
pretty much told me the same. And um with the evidence now that
I have, definitely something potentially can be
But on the other hand,
>> it's crazy to me that all of this
>> because I >> posted an image or not an image,
a little scene of Dawn to Dawn,
just
I guess if we want to really amp up an edgy post,
not even real fiction. And it's spiraling to where it's not just
personal insults to me, death threats to
but it's also where my my brother's grave
has been docked to the point to where people have the GPS coordinates,
like the actual coordinates to where it's at.
I have
the person responsible for doxing, which I thankfully have an
image here I could just show you guys. that is censored. But
the person responsible here, you know, is actively now messaging
people to um more or less come.
C CJ2 raw the Omni King 15. We spoken on your brother too. Also,
I'm Namek 62623016.
Go use the Dragon Balls to resurrect your half brother. That
needs that dude.
Apparently, he went to his brother's grave site. Jesus, man.
What the giving them my address.
People saying that it wasn't the Boruto fandom. He regardless
if this is a setup or not for the Boruto fandom, he's a part
of the Boruto community. This straight up that that's what this
individual is. He admits it himself. And on top of that, having
contact with Cree, which was the person responsible for about
a year and a half, two years
>> You still on Twitch? I am. Yeah. >> Causing the
slander to call me ape. And that has gravitated to this degree
to where I'm currently at. It is insane how we got here. It's
insane that my family is being doxed. My family is in danger.
I have to call law enforcement to be able to guard my place.
I have to
I have to worry about my social security number. So this is over
time. So we this is from the previous one, the previous video
we saw where the his fights with the Boruto fan community that
people ended up going in and doxing him and then he continues
to make content on it, right? Continues to make content on the
fact that he was doxed and it's like you could you could get
upset at this person for being a doxer, but to continually be
like my information was published. My family's information was
published. You do that stuff and then you you basically yeah
you run into major problems. No notification. Sign up for the
Twitter,
Go follow the Twitter. That will never fail because I do it myself
>> Thank you. >> Being into they were actively I
have the receipts, the messages and everything of it. All the
IDs. People actively trying
get my social security number. people trying to actively get
my phone number.
And then I have people on Twitter here and even people in my
comments on my YouTube video saying and deflecting like, "Oh,
why'd you mention the Boroto
It's members of the Boruto community." Okay. What What else would
you want me to say? Okay. I'm not playing it safe here. My life
is not just in danger. It's my girlfriend's life, my dog's life,
my cat's life, and my family as well at this point. and my brother's
grave sites is in jeopardy. I'm in a state of shock just how
vile
>> and evil total shock >> people can be. I don't
care if you hate me. You can call me a gooner. Hell, call me
a pedto, okay? I don't I don't care, okay? Cuz I know it's not
true. Call me that. I don't care. >> Well, but when you
attack
for everybody forever family at that, you're no longer in my
personal eyes even human anymore. How can you even be viewed
upon as a human when you could do something just so despicable?
I know these people get brownie points and me even posting this
video is going to make them happy,
but receipts are made now. I got the
Enough evidence.
And I'll tell you what,
>> I will 100% doing everything I can.
This is next level gross. And I just cannot believe what I have
witnessed from >> Did anyone point out that this guy is
the same face as Grrew? No, because he doesn't have the stature,
but you are right. He looks like a miniaturized version of Gru,
doesn't he? He does kind of have that face, that physioy going
>> Content creators as well on this platform that have
actively justified everything that's happened to me cuz they
don't like me. Because I'm annoying, because I'm weird. I have
massive content creators that legitimately have justified things.
That's gross, man. That's gross. We live in a society now that
it's fine to dock someone. It's fine to send in defence to someone's
family. Completely mock someone's dead brother because you don't
like them.
Was really up, guys. Don't mock this dude's dead brother. Okay?
Do not laugh that this dude's brother died. It's really up. It's
a totally up thing to say.
That's crazy. Okay. That's crazy. Now, it's important to set
some of the stuff up. Okay.
as he was going to get married, he had somebody come out and
basically do like allegations against him as well, like maybe
a couple months later. So, these two videos run off of each other.
This is the one where he announces that his engagement and then
the next one will be the one where he
I guess defends himself from allegations on the internet. All
right, stop laughing at this guy's dead brother who died. Um,
somewhere in here, by the way, we're also going to find that
he has testicular torsion and he has to go and get a ball removed.
Okay, this guy's a one ball Andy right now. Just to be totally
transparent, he's currently a one ball Andy. So, the gym stuff,
you know, he may need to talk to Techone about an exogenous hormone
hookup cuz he's he's probably rocking some pretty low tea right
now. >> YouTuber Chibi Reviews was an abuser and cheater
according to his exgirlfriend.
Who is Chibi Reviews? Controversy surrounding anime YouTuber
explored. And they uh definitely try to paint me as quite the
character by saying I'm an abuser and cheater, kind of negating
everything that's been going on with the doxing and harassing.
They uh try to label me as a right-wing extremist basically with
this article. This article basically does the exact same thing
as that article.
And I hate that I have to make this video to address this because
I have a lot of evidence to counter everything that's being said
here to smear my name once again.
But my hand's been forced. It's ironic enough that my ex actually
told me not to make the relationship public. She told me in text
messages, which I will show, but it's just it's crazy that she
couldn't even take her own advice. She labels me as an abuser.
She labels me as someone that cheated and all that when there's
a lot of evidence to show she actually is projecting.
So, let's start with the abuse.
This is a message, one of the last messages me and her had back
in uh October, November of 2022. It's been over 2 years.
To give context here, she calls me a liar because I was playing
Elden Ring by myself. I I I know that's childish. >> Wait,
why does he show above this? Like, what's going on? Uh, I played
Elden Ring when you argued for me with me for two hours doing
solo content. This argument right here is also a good example
of what I'm talking about. Okay, >> it's crazy, I know,
but basically
there's sections in Elder Ring that are solo. This was prior
to seamless co-op. >> Take a moral high ground. You really
don't see why I refrain from telling you I played Elder Ring
when you argued with me for 2 hours for doing solo content. >> Okay.
And basically, I played sections of Elder Ring solo because you
have to. That's just how it is. You can't get co-op in some areas.
Once again, prior to the mod of Seamless Co-op, I didn't tell
her about it because she always needs to know every single thing
I'm doing and gets frustrated if I want to do anything on my
own. And I was very anticipating and hyped up for Elder Ring
for years basically. I think everybody was. I mean, it's game
of the year. Anyways, she gets into an argument with me saying,
"Jacob, your actions are the reason I get upset with you. Stop
acting like some victim because I call you out on your lies and
and then you brush aside all the emotional and mental abuse towards
me." And as for the instance in the car, I was trying to run
away from you because you were having relationships with another
girl. And when I was talking to you about my assault, we got
into your car and I said, "Do you know what it feels like for
someone to come at you like this and put
I I feel like she a man. We might need to see whatever statement
she made cuz this is like this is way
hopefully he doesn't approach this way. Okay, this is turkey
tomike. I I haven't even gotten excited about this this whole
concept yet. He hasn't introduced anything. Hasn't introduced
any of the players. There's no foreplay going on at all. I don't
even know what the the context is. He's just immediately jumping
into like the middle of an argument they're having, like a heated
argument where she's talking about being >> Put my hand
up to your neck to demonstrate. I was not physically assaulting
you. I was demonstrating how my attacker took me down. I never
physically abused you.
[sighs and gasps] I never physically abused you, Jacob. The reason
I apologize for that is because I realize that you did you did
know how that you did not know how that feeling. I'm assuming
she's meant you did not know how that feeling felt when someone
attacks you. Not because I was attacking you, but because you
did understand how it feels and I still apologize for that interaction,
but I was not physically abusing you. You want to say emotional
or mental abuse, then sure, I have said very mean things, but
I never caused you any physical harm. You have literally dropped
a shovel on my head or a rake it was. Firstly, this is my response.
Firstly, it fell on you because when you >> This is like
already something that should never be online like ever. I just
don't I mean I guess she talked about stuff too. I don't know
what she talked about. This is just like way too much massive
overshares. Okay. >> Do it.
>> Basically in my front yard there was a fire pit and
there was plastic chairs. We were raking leaves and digging a
hole or whatever for a fire pit and I forget if it was a shovel
or rake but basically it was put on her chair. She sat down and
when she sat down it caused the rake or shovel to shift and then
it bumped right in the head. I didn't do it. Just literally it
moved and hit her head. Obviously, I did what you're supposed
to do. I comforted her. I was like, "Are you okay? Do I need
to take the doctor? Do you have a concussion?" All that type
of stuff. But basically, she blamed me saying, "Obviously, I
hit her in the head with it." And you can see I refute that right
here. She's like, and then she's like, "You are right about the
galaxies. I was stubborn about that. I
>> Okay, so basically um here's like the original thread
that went up that he's responding to. Okay, she this woman posted
on Twitter. Two years ago today, I was taken advant I was in
the worst relationship of my life. I was constantly taken advantage
of treated horribly. I finally said enough weighing only 70 lbs.
Today I couldn't be happier in love with my childhood best friend
st sitting at a healthy 105 lb. Okay.
Chippy was toxic. Um, only one of us is actively monetizing the
despair of breaking someone's heart over two years ago and it's
not me. Be sure but sure. Go off. Okay, hold on. Doubt it. But
I won't say anything more till I hear more because it could be
he said she said only one of us is actively monetizing the despair
of breaking someone's heart over two of over two years ago and
it's not me but sure go off king. Okay. Okay. Have you ever considered
that he's hurting too? It's been two years. Uh, two. It's been
two years. Take this from me. Let it go. And I haven't seen him
post a video about it. And then he made a post thanking everyone
for sticking with him through a hard time. The hard time of being
unfaithful. Lol. Okay, I'm not understanding the LOL there. I'm
actually being serious. Him almost wanting to end it because
that's not funny. Okay, so he apparently she got cheated on or
she says she was cheated on and
he had a hard time, I guess, coping with I don't know. I literally
don't know. I don't know at all. I l I don't know at all, man.
I don't know at all. Okay, now this would have been before he
was into the next relationship. This stuff would have been coming
out or sorry, this would have been his previous relationship
in probably 2022, 2023 before he gets married before he eventually
asks the one girl to marry him. >> Apologize for that.
That this
this goes to show
just how crazy and toxic the relationship was. [sighs and gasps]
The reason why galaxies are randomly being brought up here is
that prior to this, like a few days later or earlier before all
this went down, she was arguing me about galaxies and how like
one of the main galaxies, our galaxies, going around a super
massive black hole basically. And she was saying, "Nah, that's
not real. That's not true or whatever." And I showed her articles,
she didn't want to believe it. It was something along the lines
of that. And then she argued with me and then ghosted me basically
for days. And then it led to this situation right here.
Once again, you can see how toxic the relationship got. Anyways,
>> that sounds horrible. >> Continuing the conversation,
>> not like from It just sounds horrible that that's where
the fights would be. >> Um, she says, "You're right about
the galaxy." I respond. Also, stop trying to act like putting
your hands on my neck is okay and justified when you got upset
over me replying to comments on Twitter. So to kind of explain
what I mean here is she accuses me of cheating and talking to
another woman here and all that. But what happened was is I replied
to a Twitter post which was you know this post actually I'm going
to show right here. I was replying to this which was basically
me just you know talking about this. I I'll give actually I should
give context now. Bas basically this person Vel right here he
made this post asking what do I think >> I got the impression
that this guy was like a really he was in that weird age bracket
where he's like technically 30 or 35 but he looks very young.
Is he actually like 19? I don't think so. I'm pretty sure not.
But this is like Yeah, this is like 19. This is like high school
relationship issues. You posted on Twitter about saying you were
you said you were single on Twitter. >> I just answered
I have no idea if they're straight, you know. I have no idea
if they're single. So, he's going to he's 38. I believe that
actually, even though I have no reason to believe you because
you're just a chatter. I do believe that. Okay.
I also think he's going to try to say I feel like he's going
to present this and he's going to you told me to keep the relationship
secret. So, when I say I'm single on Twitter, that's fine, right?
When I don't I don't think, you know, I wouldn't get totally
at the guy for doing that, but I also understand why somebody
might get annoyed when you try to announce publicly that you're
single. It's like, you don't need to keep the fact that you're
in a relationship secret. Just keep our relationship >> Whatever.
And I just did that. It was just a random post I decided to respond
on. And my ex basically said, "Take this down, please, Jacob.
She assumed I was talking about it. And here's the evidence that
stop putting this relationship public. This is the argument to
that whole situation." So, giving context basically considering
me cheating for talking with anyone on Twitter. if they had a
female profile picture or whatever. If I was even responding
to comments in my YouTube comment section, she would assume it's
cheating that to give full disclosure there. That's basically
what this is. Anyways, continuing the message, you wobbled it
and it smacked my eye like always. Now, what she means by always,
um, I don't know how it happened, but most of the time she she
was clumsy and sometimes my dog would walk in the bed
and, uh, sometimes, you know, she would accidentally step on
her face. It happened. She's a small dog, my little Sheba, Costa,
but it happened. And I would get blamed for it. Basically, that's
what she's trying to say. But yeah, to give full disclosure,
I'm not trying to hide anything. That's basically what happened.
Hey, >> you wobbled it and it smacked my eye like always.
>> I don't
I don't say this was about a dog. I I guess >> I assume
if he's lying overtly here that this but it was not physically
abusing you. She's trying to downplay the neck grab she did to
me. I'll give an explanation of what she did in a moment. >> I
was just trying to make you understand my experience because
you didn't understand me. I just did it in the wrong way because
my adrenaline was high from trying to run away from you. The
reason why she was trying to run away is because of this, you
know, different arguments and stuff of like um with the messages
talking like responding to people on Twitter and all that. She
ran away in the middle of a busy street in like September.
Yeah, I think I think September, October, somewhere around there.
She got in the middle of a busy street and just started running
around in the cold and all that with no jacket. And I'm just
obviously I get out of the car and I'm like, "What are you doing?"
Like, why are you doing this? Why? Like, it's crazy. it it's
crazy like can can we agree that that's crazy anyways I'm like
come what are you doing so she was running because of stuff like
that and you know she upon her adrenal
I don't I don't see why does this I don't think this gives me
context to this message
I always I always try to think about like if you tell me a story
that's like really negative about somebody like how much does
it relate to the current thing I'm looking at and to To me, the
reason you tell the story about her getting out of the car or
something in the middle of September when it's cold out or something,
it's just to make her look crazy, right? That's the whole point.
You just want to make her look as crazy as possible based on
these messages.
The tie-in was just weak, man. >> She does physical harm
to me. Now, to explain what she did, she was in the vehicle with
me in my truck and she was in the passenger side. I was in the
driver's seat. Okay? She looked at me, yelling at me, screaming
at me, and then she did this to my neck and pushed me up against
the glass window. I hit my head up against the glass window.
Her her whole hand was around my neck and like choked me basically.
Obviously, I didn't take a picture of it because I never expected
I would be sharing this with
anyone online, but the the replies
I do wonder why he had to share. I do wonder how much like how
big did this YouTube thread this YouTube drama thread even get
1300 upvotes.
So this was the original thread. Okay,
these two screenshots
and sorry for that lady.
POS is actually the least surprising news of the day.
Like
to me none of these people like you, right?
I don't know why did you even have to
I don't I don't even know why you have to respond. How tall is
Chippy Reviews? He looks like a total like man lit 100%. I'm
I'm almost positive he's like a man total manllet. He's got to
be like 5'2.
I'm guessing he maybe he talks about it somewhere, but I just
I don't even know like what made this required. Was his audience
demanding this on Twitter? I feel like there's no way >> alone
basically showcase she just admits that she physically abused
me but downplays it to say she didn't physically abuse me.
One thing you can really draw to a conclusion here is our relationship
was very toxic. I was not perfect obviously
but she has straight up manipulated and abused me. And there's
a lot more manipulation to really talk about. So let's get into
that one. So this right here is a continuation of this. basically
her saying I was making our relationship public and all that
um when I made this post to someone. Ironically enough, this
individual doesn't like me anymore. He actually is a part of
the harassers that constantly come after me. Um but that's irrelevant
at the moment. But the point of the matter is is that uh this
individual, you know, I was just replying to them and um she
said this basically saying, "Stop making this relationship public."
And then it spiraled out of control and it got to this where
she's like, "This is all your relationships. Uh this is why all
your relationships fell." which is interesting because it was
my first relationship actually. But um stop I >> I see
from Google he is 5 foot three. Is that him saying himself that
he's 5 foot three? Cuz that's a wild thing to just put on the
internet. >> Stop trying to stand on a moral high ground
when you >> you could tell there's something about the
way he looks that you could tell just from like his face and
his shoulders that he's like totally like he's a tiny person.
It's not just the I don't know what it is. It's crazy to me that
you could like I could just tell before he says anything that
he's like literally sub 5'5.
I'm actually 5 foot three and not 5'4. I had height checked recently
and it shattered my reality. Damn.
You could like tell I feel like you could just tell from this
guy that he was tiny tiny tiny little guy. You literally told
me to die alone. She
basically said I'm going to die alone. And I can confront her
about this as you can see here. She's like this is why everybody
left you Jacob. I hope there is someone who you can maintain
focus on. I really do. But I just don't think you care to. I
doubt you feel that way after what you said earlier and just
now. You're telling me to die alone. If anyone doesn't care,
it's you. I never once said something hurtful like that. And
she's like, "You will die alone because you can't even see what
is in front of you. All you have left is your hollow uh adoration
for your fans because you just throw this one real thing away
just so you can look and comment on nude anime girls." To give
context to this, obviously I have a lot of Goonar posts now,
but back when this happened in 2022, 2021 and stuff, I didn't
really post much content like that. And you want to know why?
Because of her. I respected her boundaries. But me reviewing
fan service anime
made her upset.
Actually sounds a lot like Spinboy. Uh, that's not that's not
wrong. This guy does this is actually Spin Boy's cadence
>> Give context. That's why she >> and tone. Yeah,
it's the pitch, it's the tone, it's the >> Mentions that
if I reviewed fan service like anime and talked about it, she
would get upset like I was cheating on >> This is like
the the vocal physio of somebody who gets obsessed with something.
Spinboy luckily got obsessed with physics. He was able to become
like a an engineer, an electrical engineer, and like make massive
amounts of money. This guy got obsessed with little anime girls.
The the the dark spin boy end, I guess. the the dark end for
spin boy right here. >> I'm obsessed with the right things,
guys. Jesus. >> But one thing that really stings about
this whole situation, she straight up said, "I'm going to die
alone." And then she basically says that the only thing I have
left is my hollow adoration for you guys, the community that
has >> no the hollow adoration from them >> has been
with me, fake and fin.
So yeah, now let's talk about some other stuff since we're on
the business of really just getting my relationship out there
in the public eye, which I don't like doing, but I have to defend
myself when I literally see
>> a Reddit post about this and multiple articles already
created and my harassers now using this as evidence to smear
me. >> But like to be clear, what are these? Sportska and
what was the other one? Sportska and >> Express Tribune.
Is this I feel like definitely the first one sports ke is 100%
AI generated probably off of YouTube drama articles right like
Sportska is just YouTube drama they'll they'll like make an article
on anything that gets big enough right like these are you're
you're responding to fake articles essentially >> already
created and my harasser is now using this as evidence to smear
me obviously I need to get in front of this and talk about it.
The reason why I haven't talked about this until now,
because honestly, despite obviously the despicable stuff that
my ex has done, and there's a lot more abuse that I'm going to
talk about, because at this point, I might as well. I didn't
want no harm or any harassment to come to her for obvious reasons
because that's just not how you handle something behind the scenes
with a private relationship. It should remain private. You could
talk about certain things in passing, but stuff like this should
never be for the public. It shouldn't. I'm anime and manga review
channel for sake. And I'm having to do this. I'm having to do
so much, sis. I don't think he had to do this at all. I think
this is a total misread. There's no reason. I think you do this
because you're mad at the other person. I don't think he had
to do this whatsoever. >> Tired, man. I'm tired. Really
tired. But basically, one of the reasons why I haven't commented
on this for a while, and I knew about this post, is because at
around the same time, I was getting doxed, harassed, still am
technically trying to file a lawsuit right now, get funds for
it.
>> Oh, GoFundMe reference. We're going to get into that
in a little bit as well. involved because her name is >> he
basically he raised funds for a GoFundMe to file a lawsuit that
never got that never got filed. Okay. Or he's just I don't believe
he's shown any evidence of it. Maybe he has now, but there was
a while here where he shut down his GoFundMe
and I don't know what his response was. I didn't look into it
cuz I wasn't like that big into Chippy Review stuff a month ago.
There's some other stuff going on, but I think it's about a month
ago where these tweets start to surface of people pointing out
that he's like seemingly defrauding a >> Obviously out
there >> defrauding the people who uh >> these individuals,
these very sick and individuals targeting not just me but my
family members that are completely uninvolved, like not involved
with me at all. They would target her probably too. So obviously
I didn't want to comment on it to bring any attention to her,
negative or positive. I just But she obviously is so vindictive
and can't stand the fact that I'm moving on with my life that
she has to do stuff like this. I also like the fact that the
post she does here is to try to provide stuff with no evidence
whatsoever, but also basically say she has a a friend, a best
friend that she's now with basically that was her backup that
she's known for a while that's she's had a relationship with.
It's like, oh, so you had this guy you already knew for a while
that Anyways, let's
that was her backup. I mean, I don't know if it's her back I
I will say probably an upgrade, but also
what is that beard, bro? What is that? That beard is gross again.
Who does Why do you do beards like this? What is
Who likes this? Who does this? Come on,
>> Let's talk about some of the other stuff she did. >> Just
accept Except that God did not give you the genetics to grow
facial hair and move on.
>> Now, I don't have pictures for this one because it was
on phone calls,
but I'm just going to talk about it. I'm going to be as transparent
as possible.
One of the last conversations me and her had like on call, there's
two. One was her getting in a wreck in December of 2022. She
called me. I asked, "Is she okay? Is she safe? Etc." We were
already broke up for about a month and a half at that point,
but she she called me and medium depressed and sad. I answered,
go figure. She tells me she got wrecked. I'm asking is she okay?
You know, everything fine. She says she's fine and all that.
She was with her mother and I stayed on the phone and I honestly
didn't know what to do, what to say because of everything that
happened prior, which I'll talk about. But I stayed on the phone
for obvious reasons because it's what was right. I mean, she
almost died probably, so I was making sure she was okay. Anyways,
she eventually hung up the phone and that was the last thing
she really ever messaged me. So, that was one. The second call
prior to that happened in November, November 18th, 17th, the
day she's talking about actually. She uh I was at Books a Million.
Actually, I think I might have made a video that day about Books
a Million or commented on a tweet that day for Books a Million.
If anyone wants to go through my tweets, you can. You can look
up uh November 2022. You probably I think I have tweets I'm meeting
at Books a Million. Could be wrong. Anyways, um she called me
telling me that she was pregnant.
Obviously, I I said, "Are are you sure?" She's like, "Yes." And
I'm like, "How's the baby? Is it okay?" You know, doing the the
proper things. What you should say, what you should
>> I mean, wouldn't it be like um obviously you would have
told me this before if it was mine? This probably doesn't have
anything to do with me >> do. And I was like, "Okay, what
can we do for the child and all that?" You know, I was going
I'm thinking of options. You know, for instance, like how can
we raise this child? What can we do now? For instance, since
obviously we're separated, I still want to take care of the child.
I was willing to do what I could if I even had to pay child
Well, he said in September, right? It was in Sep September of
2022. They've been broken up for a few months. And then is it
was this December? Hold on. What was the date here? >> I
said, "Are are you sure?" She's like, "Yes." And I'm like, "Obviously."
Oh, I think I have tweets I'm meeting at Books a Million. Could
be wrong. Anyways, um she I talking about actually she uh I was
at Books a Million actually. I think I might have made a I mean
prior which I'll talk about, but I stayed on the phone for these
reasons because it's what was right. the accident. I see the
date and she was okay. Give me the date. Anyways, she eventually
hung up the phone and that was the last thing she really ever
messaged me. So, that was one. The second call prior to that
happened in November. November 18th, 17th. The day she's talking
about >> Wait, prior to that,
>> she uh I was at Books a Million actually >> lost.
Very lost. >> very lost. >> I I said, "Are are you
sure?" She's like, "Yes." And I'm like, "How's the baby? Is it
okay?" You know, doing the the proper things, what you should
say, what you should do. And I was like, >> "Oh, I think
we uh guys, I should shill for more time. Guys, if you like the
content, go ahead. You could donate to the stream. You give me
a little bit of money." But I think we actually just hit the
number. Oh, did we? No, we didn't. I lied. I I just lied to you
guys. I just lied to you guys, didn't I?
Or did I?
Whatever. We're I think we're we're basically there. But guys,
if you want to add more time to the stream, every $30 adds another
hour to the stream. Okay, let's go. 29.
We're good to go. Yeah. No, we have got another hour. Okay, every
dollar you add adds more time to the stream. You can give kicks,
you can give bits, you could give primers, you can give subs
on kick. Okay, you can buy a TTS message through Streamlabs or
Kickbot. Okay, every little bit counts. Thank you very much.
>> Why is he talking about this now? He's not talking about
this now. This is from February of 2025. This from about a year
ago where he's talking about this with an old relationship. Okay,
because this person published a tweet basically saying that her
previous people knew that she was the ex of Chibby reviews and
she just said this is a terrible relationship where she felt
she was >> Okay, what can we do for the child and all that?
You know, I was going I know for instance like how can we raise
this child? What can we do now? For instance, since obviously
we're separated, I still want to take care of the child. I was
willing to do what I could if I would even had to pay child support.
>> Then after all that, I'm assuming she was just gauging
my expression, seeing what type of person I was. She then tells
me I aborted it. Okay, that's that's pretty crazy.
I'm pregnant. Oh, what can I do about that? I aborted it. What
the [__] WHAT WHAT WHAT IS HAPPENING? WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON this phone call?
>> She She literally called me.
>> That is That is some mind ninja [__] right
there. Okay, I'm pregnant and I don't know what to do. Oh, do
you like need money? Can I take care of the kid? Even though
we're broken up, I actually aborted it. What the >> to
say she was pregnant and then when I started asking what to do,
she said she aborted it.
>> Yeah, hold on. True. She She got him with the uh she
got him with the present versus past tense. Okay. I said I was
pregnant, not that I am pregnant. Idiot.
>> Do you realize how evil that is?
Like that is
>> there's no way he's going to cry on
things you can do to someone.
To give full disclosure here, I know I'm not perfect. >> I
made a lot of mistakes.
>> I think this is this is where you start to get why people
really don't like this guy, okay? Cuz listen, that's like a little
up. Sure. But is it up enough to go and cry on a video on your
400,000 sub channel,
right? Is it that level of up? Why the would you do that? >> And
posting what I'm talking about here is definitely going to have
a lot of people not like me now.
>> Yeah, if that even happened. True. >> I'm tired,
man.
I'm really tired of just like if it's not harassers and doxers
and it's my family/x
always just >> there is always somebody kicking this guy
down. >> Get my composure back. Basically, she lied or
I don't know if she did because it was on call, but she called
me telling me she was pregnant and then she had an abortion apparently
in the same call literally after she gauged my reaction, I'm
assuming, and then just to hurt me to try to see if I was going
to stay with her or not. And then she did that. I I don't know,
but it's very clear just from what I have shown alone. And I
I definitely have more screenshots and different things if I
go digging.
She was not mentally okay. Like there there was a lot of issues
and she obviously had a bad past. I mean, she kind of hints >> as
opposed to as opposed to as opposed to. She's obviously totally
crazy, guys. Me, I'm totally normal. Also, look at observe my
background. Observe my background. Okay,
guys. Nobody treats me seriously. Nobody takes me seriously,
guys. >> I showed But it still gives no excuse to the heinous
and horrible actions she has done to me and what she >> Hold
on. There's a there was a tweet that went along with this. Give
me a second. Somebody linked this earlier. grown ass man crying
in front of a camera with an with with an S death ES death S
death poster and his figure collection in the back and people
want us to take him seriously. Why does nobody take me seriously?
Why does nobody take me seriously?
Oh, whoops.
Clicked on uh the dicker stream. >> She clearly is to me.
>> That doesn't even get into the other stuff. She uh what
really started the gradual drifting apart comes down to two different
things. We were long distance. She lived in Canada and I live
in the United States. And when co our relationship, you know,
started to get fractured. I mean, I think everybody can understand,
you know, long distance and co times. It's u yeah you border
shut down, can't go through all the mask mandates, everything.
You get the point. But that stretched an already stretched relationship.
But what really I think did the nail in where I stopped I started
drifting >> and this was another call I had with her in
2021 and at the time I should have listened to my best friends
I play games with for context. I should have listened to their
advice and been done at that point. But I am an individual that
doesn't like to
to just throw things away like sunk cost fallacy. I think that's
the proper word despite all the toxicity and the manipulation.
And obviously I showed examples of physical abuse.
She called me one day because her brother apparently closed the
door on her when she was home because she was carrying waters
or something and she um her her brother didn't like open the
door properly and just like closed the door on her. She got upset
about that. So she called me to start venting and then started
basically saying she was
going to kill herself.
Obviously I take that very seriously. So I said, "Hey, don't
do this. You can't do that." I'm like, I'm like, I'm going to
get off the phone right now and I'm going to call your mom for
she can make sure you're okay because FYI, I'm sitting here in
Tennessee, United States. She's in Canada. So, I can't just physically
go there instantly when the border is also shut down thanks to
CO. So, only thing I can do is to call the local police or her
mom. So, I was about to hang up on her to call her mom cuz I
was genuinely concerned. And she's like, "If you hang up that
phone right now, I'll be dead before you make that call." I stayed
on the call obviously until she finally decided to end the call
herself. And then I called my best friend and I cried to him
for about 2 hours. Hey,
Yeah, I just I can't ever get behind this. It's this level of
like emotional oversharing on a stream. I just can't get behind
it. I can't get behind it. It's so
It's so crazy to me why you would do this. I I just I can't imagine,
>> Not one of my favorite moments in life. I'll be honest
with you. Probably one of the worst
Probably one of the worst things I've ever went through. I'm
not even going to lie. But
>> worst thing you've gone through so far. This was less
than a year ago. Just wait. Just wait. You think it's one of
the worst things that you've gone through. It's going to seem
like just very tiny, very small. Okay. Worst thing that's happened
to you so far.
>> Anyways, [laughter] she uh
she had multiple instances of abuse
>> This will all be put into perspective for him. >> Obviously,
a lot of this stuff happened on calls, so I can't just provide
calls because I don't record that. I never expected to record
that stuff. But
all I'm saying about the situation
is that I tried to follow her wishes, not make anything public.
That's why I didn't talk about it ever, but she decided to do
this. Alongside of everything else that's been going on with
harassment and all that, I obviously have to acknowledge this.
I can't just let my character continuously get muddied and thrown
into the dirt. I I can't allow that, especially when the accusations
are completely false. To be completely blunt, was I perfect?
No. I I had moments where I probably said mean things. I admit
that. I argued obviously like any toxic relationship would. I
was not perfect by any means. I'm not trying to act like I was.
But I find it crazy and odd. >> But this person is crazy.
Okay, this I was not perfect, but this person's out of her mind.
>> Even despite everything she
>> It's been years. I'm now say >> prior about to
get married to her, having a whole life with her, trying to get
this lawsuit stuff under control and give go after the people
that's not just harassing me but my family. And then she decides
to do stuff like this. And I want to remind everybody when this
post was made was literally not like just a month later after
the doxing. She knew. She she stalked my stuff. She always stalked
my likes, my comments, replies. She stalked it. So she knew.
She made this to damage my character even more. But she also
made this around the same time I was actively talking about my
fiance with like the proposal to >> uh this is rough. I
The other thing is is like I don't have a good like objective
metric for his behavior. So the thing I usually look for is if
I have, you know, some proof of their behavior when they try
to explain it. It's like how do they explain it? Do they actually
analyze it accurately, but I don't have any understanding of
like what his personal behavior was in this relationship? So
it's hard for me to make that, you know, use that use that usual
yard stick. Sometimes there's like actual posts or actual, you
know, explanations from people, but yeah, he's not he's not explaining
anything.
He's totally ignoring it. >> Just like we're spending time
and I'm having a good time. I'm moving on. >> So he's in
a new relationship with it a pretty short period of time. Uh,
I don't think so. This is like 2022. He said they broke up. So,
technically it could have been a year before he got into a new
relationship. >> All in my life. And to give another bombshell
drop. You remember how I was depressed in 2022, 2023. And I talked
about I made videos on it. I think if you follow my channel,
you know about this. Made a few vlogs talking about it. Had high
blood pressure and everything because of this because of the,
you know, trying to get over that that whole situation. And I
tried to move on. I tried to move on, but every time I try to,
someone wants to drag me back down into the dirt. I don't like
making this public. I don't like talking about this, but it's
got to be said. If you think less of me, anyone that's watching
this far into the video, it's fine. I
But I feel like it's important to talk about it. I didn't want
to. It is the internet. Especially when you're dealing with continuous
harassment and doctors and people that put bounties on your heads
and exes now trying to smear your
It It happens.
People dig up anything to really try to just >> a bounty.
>> Thankfully, I have a very supportive fiance that loves
me a lot. Without her, I don't think I would be able to handle
everything that continuously happens. I'm going to be blunt,
but I can thanks to her. And so, I move forward. She's been very
supportive of me. And
now, I think given that this is February 2025, I do believe this
would be the current fiance. Okay. Kind of rough, man. Huh. The
thing that allows me to move on through this is that I've got
a new fiance. Okay. I've got a new fiance who would never treat
me badly, who would never treat me like this person treated me.
I've got a new fiance who's really just fixed all of the problems
with my life. Oh no. >> The reason why I didn't address
this on Valentine's Day, I think it goes stated, but I think
I should say it. I didn't want to post this video on Valentine's
Day because anyways, >> inappropriate comment, Porter Beller.
People dig up anything like your brother. Inappropriate comments
say obviously there's more stuff I could
>> Very funny amateur character. I don't want to make her
look terrible or anything like that. That's not my full like
that's not my intention at all. But when you start doing this
and you're accusing me, especially in an environment that obviously
is very anti-me, you know what's gonna happen. >> You You
actually just made me realize or remember that Deeperama, another
another chatter. Okay. He had some He had some fantastic tweets
today. If people got to look at my likes, it would just be a
bunch of Deeperama likes. Okay. I like go through and I find
stream content and then it's Deeperama tweets all the time. >> She
knew. She knows cuz now this is being used as ammo against me
and you have people literally making news articles about it.
Like not a very flattering picture though, by the way.
one last thing I will drop
and she's going to probably if she watch this video, she will
watch it on her Instagram. She likes to talk about cheating and
stuff.
She posted a lot of explicit photos and everything on her Instagram
and was even selling pictures of herself. I didn't know about
this until I investigated the Instagram and stuff thanks to everything
going on. But yeah, actively while we were together in 2021 2022,
she was selling photos. I'm not going to show those for obvious
reasons, for to reasons, for YouTube. But she was they're still
up to this day. PROBABLY SHE >> OH, SHE WILL she will delete
those. It's going to happen. But screenshots, they're all there
for proof. And >> so this guy's a he is >> evidence.
[laughter] I need them. I need them. I want this to be done.
I don't wish her. >> Dude, it's funny that like
>> man, how do I explain it to people? >> I do. Marty
Epste, thank you for the five gifted. Super appreciate it, buddy.
I do feel like all of these guys would hate umh how do I explain
this? The
the way you deal with internet controversy with women is you
just paint them all as mentally ill like every single time. Every
single time it's just all just mentally ill.
It's it's very funny how how consistent it is. There's that one
and Hassan is bad. The same group of people use the same two
defenses for all wrongs in the world. It's it's like so it's
like clockwork every time. It's very funny. Okay.
[laughter] I didn't see this one. Okay,
hold on. Chibi Reviews posted this. Is it possible for an otaku
to find love? Is it truly possible
for an otaku to find love? Yes, it is possible. As someone that
is a short, nerdy, I managed to find someone. If I can, you all
can, too. It's not about It's just about not giving up, guys.
Believe it. Okay? You can make it. You can make it. You can make
it on February 7th, 2026.
ah boy.
Deeperama quote tweet. If you laugh, you go to hell,
dude.
Well, we're all we're all gone. Okay, we're all we're all gone.
We're all
Okay, we're all
God.
Now, I do want to go through his his vlog where he just where
he announc uh his vlog where he announces his engagement. Dude,
I his vlog where he announces his engagement. Okay. This is from
November of 2024, about a year and a half ago. Okay. Well, a
year and four months ago.
This surely will take no pleasure from watching him discuss how
happy he is, how perfect his partner is, how
Surely will take no pleasure out of this. Hey guys, it's been
a bit since I uh did a video like this. This isn't like my normal
anime manga related video. This is me just talking with all of
you guys one to one. Just discussing things that's been going
on, giving you guys a little Wait, I just noticed something now
that I'm looking at dates. Hold on.
Here we go. February. That the posts from Chibi Reviews X
were from November of 2024. Oh, you definitely should have let
these go. somebody figured them out like way later,
but these were from November and he responded in February of
2025, like four months later.
I would have just let those go, man. One YouTube drama thread.
Damn. Damn. >> Little bit of an update. All sorts of little
things. It's been about probably maybe a year, maybe even a year
and a half since I uh I did a video kind of like this, like a
vlog style. I'm obviously not outside right now because the time
of me recording this, it's um already getting dark outside. It's
4:00 in the afternoon and I already see the sun setting, which
is just crazy. That's what fall winter type of seasons do. But
uh so I can't sit outside and um do that. And even if I were,
it's incredibly cold. I don't want to bundle up in a jacket.
I rather sit in my pajamas and be comfy. But uh jokes aside,
well, that's not really a joke. I I do wear pajamas anytime I
sit down and record. Um let's just let's talk about things. So
you probably
Dude, uh, I can see where Teetone got his vlog style from. Okay,
this is unironically if you just take the voice, put it on, if
you just take the voice and swap it out. This is just TeeOne,
right? It's the exact Teetone style of vlog. You saw the news
a few days ago that I talked about where I proposed. And to give
a brief, you know, backstory to this, basically, yes, I proposed
to my girlfriend and she she said yes. She she she literally
looked at me at first. I I remember it gives me so much joy.
It's something I will always remember for the rest of my life.
But she looked at me and like with eyes of shock cuz she was
like, "Is this really happening?" And then when I opened up the
box, the ring box and all that, she legitimately just like said
yes. And it was she started shaking. It was a very sweet sweet
moment. It's honest. >> You will remember it for the rest
of your life. Yes, you will absolutely remember it for the rest
of your life.
>> Something that I will never forget for the rest of my
life. It is probably one of the best moments I've ever experienced
in my life. And it is definitely something I wish upon anyone
honestly to at least experience that
>> You would wish that on anyone to experience that joy.
I can't I should Don't laugh. Don't laugh. It's not funny. Everything
was taken. All of these HAPPY MEMORIES DESTROYED. DO not laugh.
this is not funny boy in that moment it is it's beautiful it
really is but um besides obviously the proposal and all that
and her saying yes haven't necessarily planned out exactly what
we're going to fully do for the wedding you know that's for the
future but uh for now though yes I am
not that part of the it's decided within a year it's decided
okay it is decided oh two years sorry within a year and two years
sorry a year and four months a year and four months we decided
what we're doing at the wedding. It's all >> an engaged
man. It's um
>> strange. It's It's really strange. I mean, I'm sitting
here at 29 years old and all that. I did not think because I
was getting up to the point in my life where I didn't know if
that was going to be possible, but here I am. And uh all I'm
going to say is is if I could find someone unironically,
you guys can straight.
It's rough.
He keeps saying that. Uh, guys, if I can find someone, anyone
can find someone. If I can find someone, anyone can find someone.
I feel like all we need now for Clevicular to totally take over
the internet is for this guy to post a picture of his uh his
best friend of 10 years and that guy to be a looks maxer.
You're going to find you're going to find out like Clvicular
was this guy's best friend of 10 years. All right. He took took
this guy's wife or something. I swear. And it'll just be it'll
be so over. Okay. Every incel forum will be totally vindicated.
It'll be so over.
>> Okay, cuz I'm a weirdo. I am not normal. I mean, hell,
you look at my room. Look at my wall scrolling behind me, my
PC to the manga I've collected to the stuff I talk about on the
channel. I'm a I'm a pretty weird guy. I I I am. I'm definitely
some Dude, this
this is another reason you don't overshare is because sometimes
you'll feel really elated. Okay. You'll feel really elated that
like things are going well for you. Your life is going great.
But sometimes, especially when you got some haters on the internet.
Oh, it's rough, man. Look, I'm so weird. It's like no woman would
ever love me enough to stay with me. No woman would ever love
me enough to stay with me. I'm so weird. You'd think that no
woman would ever love me enough to stay with me, but she does
love me enough to stay with me. It's like, [laughter]
just wait, man. Just wait. We're like, we're less than 2 years
away from you finding out that that's not true. You just made
some up. Okay. Turns out there's a reason to not just hang up
anime posters and be a total degenerate lollycon. Turns out that
might put almost any woman off. >> One that would cause
people to um give a a weird look to and potentially walk away
from. But uh obviously that did not happen. And you know, >> it's
it burns. Every comment burns.
>> My girlfriend accepted me for who I was. Well, now fiance,
actually, I got to get used to saying that. She is my fiance
>> I don't even think I can pause for all of the the painful
statements. I don't even think I can pause for all of them. >> But,
uh, you know, my my fiance, she she basically accepted me who
I was, and she's actually a very big anime manga fan as well.
She actually plays a lot of games, too. >> Yeah, this is
a good point, uh, Shrekhavior.
Okay, this is a good point. I don't think I could date a man
with tons of anime posters and I love anime and manga. It's like,
yeah, or manga, whatever you want to say. I I don't think there's
anything wrong with like liking the occasional anime, but Jesus
Christ, man. Like like you've you've dedicated stuff to this
in a way that really truly disturbs me. Truly truly disturbs
me. You want the uh you want the snake cringe moment? >> The
game she plays, even though I don't play it, she plays Overwatch
quite a bit. Not the biggest fan of Overwatch, going to be honest
here, but she's a big fan. She actually was a master. Like, she
was a master at one point. FPS gamers. Uh-oh. This might be a
really nice tiein to the 10 Kaidday situation. Do we have to
look up the 10's Kaidday situation? FPS girls,
I think we found the problem, haven't we? You're a girl. You
play first-person shooters. These ain't loyal. These Okay. Especially
you. You don't play support.
>> These ain't loyal. Okay. donated through >> Hello
Ruben Ruben
>> more like she gone >> thank you very much for
the three Ruben Ruben a rare miss not often but a rare I I I
get it I do get it but I
to me that makes it better but I do have to react appropriately
okay I appreciate those donations with the with the misses even
more than anything else okay at Overwatch rank competitive so
pretty insane honestly she's >> she's what here but she's
a big fan she actually was a masters like she was a master at
one point at >> Yeah, master is not that impressive.
It's not It's not I actually just realized that I could hit I
could easily hit eternity rank in rivals by the way on any role.
I saw how big the pools were in like eternity and rivals. I could
easily do that like 100%. Super [__] easily. Um I
could easily hit grandmaster super easily. It would have taken
like I I do think like another two weeks to three weeks, maybe
a month. I would have hit GM super easily. I'm not going to ever
do it now. Okay, we're moved on to WoW. We got to move on to
>> Overwatch rank competitive, so pretty insane, honestly.
She's um pretty good gamer, honestly. She she can kick my ass
at those type of games pretty easily. But I've always been a
guy that really focuses more or less on the RPG stuff and the
single player games and all >> Is he bragging about when
he talks about her Overwatch rank? Yes. Yes.
Yes, he is. And I think this just lends even more credence, by
the way, to the idea that with his gaming group, okay, he likes
playing solo games. This is why his friend group next to him,
okay, cuz the other guy was just better. This guy sucks. This
guy is actually admitting to sucking at Marvel Rivals, at Overwatch,
any multiplayer game. He is literally confessing.
other guy, that other dude, his best friend at 10 years, total
loser, homeless loser, makes no money, but he is he is, you know,
one above all on the Marvel Rivals ladder. And that's what his
girlfriend really wanted most was just a great Marvel Rivals
player. Okay. Unlucky Chibi Reviews. Women can't help it. Okay.
Never date a first-person shooter player as Tens learned. Okay.
>> So, makes >> I don't know the Ten's Kaidde situation
at all. I just assume that Tens got screwed over for some reason.
I don't know why. Okay, I do kind of want to look into it though.
I enough people have asked me about the Ten's Kaidde situation
that I may have to look into it at some point. We may have to
avail ourselves of that situation and figure out who's right
and who's wrong. >> She would probably destroy me there.
Um, with that being said though, I will say that um, this past
year has been
so wild. Like to the whole aspect of like
my girlfriend now becoming my fiance, to the proposal, but to
you guys as well. You guys have legitimately been such a huge
part of
my life this last year. Like, I'm not going to lie. Uh before
like I met my girlfriend and all that, well fiance,
um I was not in a good spot. I think you guys remember when I
made my vlogs, the last time I really sat down and made a vlog,
I talked about like my mental health. I talked about my like
anxiety and all sorts of stuff like that. Just how I was not
necessarily doing that good mentally. But after getting a lot
of help, you know, trying to work out a little bit, hiking or
at least walking around and all that, I I got in a better headsp
space. It was thanks to a lot of people around me, my friends
online, to some family members, and then you guys as well that
really helped me get back on track. And I I've already made a
public post about this like um on YouTube comments, like the
YouTube community section, and even on Twitter. I talked about
like how >> it's very techone coded. That's what we said
when we opened it up. It's very very very Tecttonike. I wouldn't
be shocked if Tekton watches or watched a lot of this guy's content
and took the vlog style from him. Okay. >> Oh, the theory
is Kaid cheated on Tens with a mutual friend.
Uh, well,
first person shooter girls, man. Not even once. Your girl plays
Overwatch. Uhoh. Uhoh.
Your girl plays Valerant. Uhoh.
Your girl plays Marvel Rivals. Uhoh.
You know, there was >> these girls are are ladder climbers
in more ways than one. Okay. Every single
>> A while back, two years ago, I made a statement, like
a moment to myself where like I was going to make videos daily.
And um
it it's something I made a promise to myself to have a commitment
to never give up, to never allow the dark urges or thoughts within
my head really take over, and to always have a goal to strive
for. It was a daily goal. It might not seem like something really
massive, but it was a pretty big goal for me. It was something
that allowed me to always have something to do every single day
to get myself out of bed. And that small little motivation really
did help me. And so I made a commitment to always basically do
a video every single day for the last two years now. It's been
over two years. I have not missed one day of a daily upload.
Sometimes I upload two to three videos a day, which is wild honestly.
But uh anyways, I made that commitment to myself because I didn't
want to forget about how much you guys, the community, mean to
me.
>> Wasn't there something like go something like going
on in Jaw court about someone named Ria? Yeah, there was. Yeah,
I think there was some drama around that. Yeah, another first-person
shooter thing. Um I don't know if there's like a lack of faithfulness
going on there.
There's probably like a
Oh, do I want to be indelicate about this? Is there like there's
there's like this um allegory of the town bike, you know? I believe
that's what was going on there. I I like but pretty out in the
open that in a way that I don't really feel bad about saying
it. Other people were very aware. I don't think it was like a
lack of faith, you know, a lack of faith thing,
but also just allowing me to recognize and realize that, you
know,
I it I don't want to give up. I never want to give up. I want
to keep moving and I want to keep getting better and healthier.
And if it wasn't for your guys' help and stuff, I want to be
honest with you and then some of my friends as well, I probably
would not be here. And now that I [laughter] This guy's constantly
alluding to the fact that he's wanted to kill himself. I think
there's only so many times you could do that, man. There's only
so many times you could do that before it starts to just ring
hollow. Okay. If it wasn't for you guys keeping me up, I would
kill myself. Not an obligation, by the way. You don't have to
like watch and subscribe and donate, but if I if it weren't for
you guys, I'd just killed myself immediately, guys. Okay? Just
>> Have a fiance. It's crazy that how dark my life was
to me. Like when I was at that time period 2 years ago, how dark
everything seemed to me and now two years in the future where
I'm at right now, I'm literally
about to be a married man. That that's that's crazy. It's It's
actually an insane
thing that I just I never thought like if you would have told
me two years ago that I would be in the situation I'm currently
at, I would have laughed. I might have just been like, "You're
lying." Just to make me feel better or something, but no, here.
Ah, it hurts. It hurts. It hurts again. It hurts again.
Um, I thought he had a Twitter post of him in the hospital because
he actually attempted it. Well, he basically said he drove out
near the ocean and then he was drinking and he said he was moments
away from doing it and then he went to the hospital, but I think
if they admitted him to the hospital is like truly I don't know
that they release him the next day.
Like I don't think that's a next day release kind of thing. You
know what I mean?
Um yeah, I I just don't know. >> Here I am. And it's just
it's crazy. And one inspiration or aspect I want anyone to take
out from this whole video. If there's one thing, never give up.
There's always a tomorrow. There's always more to life. And always
strive to be the best you possibly can be every single day.
Not that any of that is wrong, okay? Not that that is any Not
that any of that is
That said, uh he could have had alcohol poisoning or something.
That's usually a next day release. That would make more sense
to me if he was drinking a ton and like falling over drunk that
they didn't feel comfortable sending him to the drunk tank. They
might have felt comfortable sending him to a hospital and then
they release him the next day. Like they might have thought,
"Oh, we need to get this guy's stomach pumped or something and
send him to the hospital."
Yeah. None of that is wrong about like uh never give up or whatever.
It's just weird coming from him. And also, you know, in retrospect,
I have no idea why anybody would ever like me. I'm like a weirdo.
I have no idea why anybody would ever like me. All of my [__]
is weird. I do a lot of weird stuff. I I can't I never thought
a woman would ever like me. Oh well, it turns out you are correct.
That may be the only patient or or intelligent thing you've ever
said should be reviews. Yes. Thank you. I know it's taxing. It's
tiring. It's annoying. It can be stressful, but never give up
because honestly, if I would have gave up, I wouldn't be here
and I would not uh have the love of my life. And so all I'm going
to say is is guys,
thank you for would not be here if it wasn't for all of you.
I really wouldn't. So, um, just thank you guys and I love you.
I just wanted to make this brief video cuz >> this guy
needs the Darius advice. I did give that advice to like Techone
viewers earlier tonight. Okay, I gave that advice as I gave that
advice as best I could given the restrictions of the toos. All
right. >> But also to just like tomorrow being like a holiday
for, you know, United States, you know, Thanksgiving. I don't
know. I just I felt like giving thanks to all of you guys. >> But
anyways, be safe, stay healthy, and I love you all. Chibi out.
>> Wow. Now, I can't get over how awesome it is that his
latest video pops up with him looking smug about his proposal
and how well it's going. His life is awesome. His life is awesome.
His life is awesome. And then I lost everything. I lost everything.
Okay. I lost everything. I lost everything.
it's it's just terrible, isn't it? It's just terrible. I do think
it would be awesome for Chippy Reviews to review this video himself
very very soon. Okay,
sorry, that's my glass.
Okay, we've got this. Now, I might do a little bit of Nux content.
I think there's one or two pieces of Nux content I want to watch.
Okay, going over some of the lies and [__]
And then what else do we got? We've got a couple other things
that I can go through tonight. I'm not totally sure what I want
to do. We could look into the Chibi Reviews, GoFundMe stuff for
sure. There's a few other things I was thinking about. I'm not
totally sure. What I'm going to do is I'm going to click on I
lost everything. I'm going to let this play for a little bit
so you guys can watch it. Okay, just in case people are coming
in late, maybe they don't understand why we're laughing at this
guy. Okay, one, he's a totally fake loser. Two, he's a open at
a vowed. And three, he's an open and avowed open and avowed techone
supporter. He's a part of that two conservative grifter pipeline.
We don't like those guys. Okay, we don't like those guys. We're
not fans. All right, total spur. >> I'm making this video.
>> Let me skip forward a little bit past some of the package.
Okay,
that. I really have.
So, you all saw the post. So you all I've seen, you've seen what
I've said in the last
24 how many hours? I don't know. It's just
I'm just going to give you a [sighs] full rundown of just everything
that that happened.
>> Maybe I'm oversharing
>> used against me to mock me or whatever.
>> Done, Pete. Well, like I said, I'm saying all this just
to clear my head just because if I say it,
it's it's done. It's it's over. Like, I'm able to just process
everything at least a little bit better. So, on the 11th of February,
I discover I discover my
cheating on me with my best friend of 10 years. I confronted
her about this [sighs] and uh she apologized and I >> Oh,
okay. Hey, I'm back. Hello. Hello. Hello. I heard a donation.
Marmma dude, thank you for the two gifted subs. That's another
hour on the stream. Very cool. Thank you very much, Marma dude.
Was that for Yeah. Yeah. That's another hour on the stream for
sure. Two 2122.
Boom. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate it.
Okay.
He has that lead head cadence. H I don't know what that means.
Oh no. The moment you you say you're oversharing, that means
you should stop immediately. Yes, it does, Trucker Joe. Yes,
it does. But thankfully for everybody, he did not stop sharing.
Okay.
Being with her already for multiple years and then finding out
my best